Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Lay's and Walkers
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
We'll start with a quick note
to explain their different names.
Walkers used to be its own company
and was the most popular
crisp brand in the UK.
Frito-Lay actually
acquired Walkers in 1989,
but they decided to still
use the brand name in the UK
so all that brand loyalty
didn't go to waste.
In the UK, Walkers crisps
come in five portion sizes.
A multipack 25-gram bag,
a 32.5-gram bag,
a 45-gram bag,
a 65-gram bag,
and a 175-gram sharing bag.
The smallest that's in the
multipack bag is 28 grams.
Then we move up to a 78-gram bag,
a 226-gram bag,
and then our party-size bag, 368 grams.
That means our biggest bag is 110% larger
than the biggest bag in the UK.
A few other things to note.
In the UK, if you get a flavored bag,
it's the same weight as
the ready-salted version.
Whereas in the US, our flavored bags
weigh less than the
original-flavored bags.
Take this bag of salt and vinegar chips.
It weighs 7.75 ounces,
compared to the classic
regular-salted 8-ounce bag.
Back in 2014, PepsiCo claimed the reason
there is a slightly higher price per ounce
for flavored chips is the added seasoning.
OK, before we continue,
they're telling us,
"Weighs less, costs more
because we're adding more
seasoning." Right, guys?
Well, I got a question for you, PepsiCo.
[grunting]
What does that say there?
Says "Lightly Salted."
So I understand this has
less salt than these guys?
Huh.
Closer inspection: right
there, 7 3/4 ounces.
Not the full 8.
If there's less seasoning
and salt in here,
why is it a smaller
ounce and a higher price?
They're stealing my salt!
Salt, literally the cheapest
thing on the planet.
We have a whole ocean full of it,
and yet they're still skimping on it!
Your move, PepsiCo.
This 28-gram bag of chips
supposedly has 15 chips in it,
according to Lay's website.
Well, they lied about the salt,
what else are they lying about?
I'm going to count the crisps
in this 25-gram bag for comparison.
These chips are demolished.
I feel like it's more than 15.
This is what we call the
stoner-math section of "Food Wars."
We do the math so you
stoners don't have to.
All right. So, one, two.
That's a whole one.
Little peephole.
Absolute Frankenstein of a crisp, this.
Arguably not one
put-together chip in here.
OK, let's just ...
that's a chip, that's a chip, right?
So, the issue there is that the crisps
are all vastly different sizes.
Like, this one, just one
crisp, but it's tiny,
whereas this one, also
one crisp, but way bigger.
And we've ended up with 22.
Of all the arbitrary
things we do on this show,
this has to be the most arbitrary.
Wow, look at that, everyone!
They gave me an extra chip.
16 instead of 15.
The last thing we wanted to check
was how much air you're
getting in your bags.
Walkers in the UK are kind of notorious
for seemingly underfilling the bags.
We're going to find the volume of the bag
and then the volume of the crisps inside
to find out just how much
wasted space there is.
What I need to do is
carefully open the bag
just enough to let the air out,
and then I'm going to
try and powder these,
like just crush them as far as I can,
and then measure the volume
of the powder in this thing.
First I gotta crumble it up.
[whispering] Crushing bags with Harry.
[bag crackling]
Oh, this is like ... [growls].
It's quite therapeutic.
It feels like I'm giving a massage.
Just, like, the world's worst massage.
I need something to kind of tamp it down,
'cause the air is stuck in
there, so I'll just use,
oh, I don't know,
this pair of nunchucks!
Oh, yeah!
Now, step two is going to be
to find the volume of the bag itself.
So we're going to fill the bag with water
to try and find the volume.
Oh, God. Oh.
Tiny bit more.
Perfect.
Sarah: OK. We did it!
But now I have to get it in there
without spilling it everywhere.
Three, two, one, go.
[laughing]
Sarah: Oh, that is perfect!
Harry: Look at that!
That went pretty well.
We didn't spill water everywhere.
Oh, my God, it's, like,
right to the top there.
That's crazy how that worked. OK.
Buchi and Wumi are making
a triumphant return.
Go and watch the Oreos episode
if you haven't already.
Some of that,
and then measure the rest.
Y'all brought number two!
[laughing] Oh, God.
Can you see the bits of stuff
floating around in there?
So, according to my trusted friend
PercentageCalculator.net,
around 90% of a 25-gram
Walkers bag is wasted space.
I don't know what the math is
I'm supposed to be figuring out, I forgot,
but whoever's editing this,
take all those numbers,
and this is the conclusion.
Now, that air is actually
there for a reason.
It's nitrogen gas, which
helps preserve the chips
and also acts as a cushion
to stop them getting smashed in transit.
I mean, imagine what it'd be like
if it didn't have all that air in there.
So, as much air as there is in there,
it's actually vitally important.
If anything, they should put
more air in these things,
'cause these things, they turn into dust.
Into dust!
Here are all the Walkers
products from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here is everything
you can only get in the US
and not in the UK.
I am losing my mind, let's go!
I want to start with a couple
of linguistic/stylistic differences
rather than anything else.
For example, in the UK,
we call our classic Walkers ready salted,
as opposed to original.
I believe this is a reference
to the very old days of crisps
where what you would actually get
is just, like, a bag of plain crisps,
and then you would have
to add your own salt.
These ones are ready salted.
You don't have to add any
salt, it's already on there.
One stylistic difference
that's worth pointing out
is that in the UK, our salt
and vinegar chips are green.
I will say Walkers is kind of
the only brand that does that.
And then we're on to some
actual exclusive flavors.
We'll start with this one,
which is cheese and onion.
Now, Americans don't
have cheese and onion,
which might shock a few Brits
because it's one of the
most popular flavors here.
Instead they have I think,
like, cheddar and sour cream
and sour cream and onion.
It just ruins your breath.
Your breath smells so bad after these.
How did I get so lucky?
I love chips, I love different flavors,
I love trying new varieties,
and I hate paying for it.
So this is perfect for me.
I'm going to start with a flavor
that I never even heard
of, cheddar jalapeño.
Oh, my God!
I like the kick on these.
It reminds me of the
cheddar and sour cream,
which I can't believe you guys don't have.
This flavor took over about 20 years ago,
and I don't know why it's
so good, but it is good!
Love this flavor.
If I had to rank them though,
I'll put the jalapeño above that one,
the cheddar and sour cream.
Sour cream and onion, I
don't even got to open these.
Sour cream and onion, classic flavor.
I mean, barbecue in America is amazing.
I mean, this is just a
classic, classic flavor.
Oh, man. Fantastic.
But how does that compare to
sweet Southern heat barbecue?
Southern heat!
Oh, yeah.
I put these above these.
Then we got honey barbecue.
How sweet is this one going to be?
You got greedy with the sweetness.
Ooh, chili lime.
Yeah, dude. I've never had these before.
Chilies and limes.
See that? Chilies, limes.
Fantastic combination.
Ooh, I don't know how I feel about these.
It's like, I wasn't into them before,
but now I kind of can't stop eating them.
Another iconic British flavor
that's also exclusive is prawn cocktail.
Brits became really
obsessed with prawn cocktail
in, like, the '70s, I think it was.
It just became a sort of trendy thing
to serve at dinner parties.
I'm not mad about that, because
it is a really tasty one.
It just kind of tastes tomatoey,
because it was usually served with
a tomato mayo-Worcestershire
sauce combination.
Next we've got a personal
favorite of mine,
which is Marmite crisps.
God, I love Marmite. Marmite is fantastic.
The slogan was, "You either
love it or you hate it,"
and it does still ring true,
I think, for most people.
I'm firmly in the love-it camp.
Bit of tang from the amount
of salt that's in there.
Fantastic crisp.
Harry was nice enough to send
me some of his UK exclusives,
which I'm going to look at right now.
Where do I want to start?
I guess all start — oh, no.
Marmite.
I don't get why people love Marmite.
Ugh!
I mean, it tastes exactly like ass.
I hear millennials like that,
so maybe that's a selling point for them.
They should actually be
like, "Tastes like ass,"
'cause the kids are into that
these days, but I am not.
Then we have a couple of meaty options,
which I'm surprised you guys
don't have in the States.
We kind of love combining
crisps and meat, as it seems,
starting with these roast chicken crisps.
Another meaty option is
these, which is smoky bacon.
Then we have these ones,
which are tomato-ketchup-flavored Walkers.
In my opinion, prawn cocktail does ketchup
better than ketchup does ketchup.
And then for the last of
our standard crisp flavors,
we have pickled onion.
Pickled onion's another thing
that's kind of iconic to British culture
in the same way that maybe
prawn cocktail or Marmite are,
just 'cause it's quite traditional
to find a big jar of pickled
onions or pickled eggs in pubs,
and you'd have one of those as a bar snack
while you're drinking your pint.
The complaint I often have against pickles
and pickled onions is that
they're not tangy enough.
And these are very tangy,
so good job, Walkers.
Puckering pickled onion.
What does that mean?
Puckering? Like [makes kissing sound]?
Like I'm being kissed by a pickled onion?
Yo, these suck!
Hey, Joe, can I try some of those?
Hey, Harry, try some of
these great American flavors!
Thank you!
Let's start with the limón.
That's what I've got in my hand.
Ooh, those are lemony!
Whew!
I don't think I've ever
had a citrus crisp before.
That is not something
that we have in the UK.
Those are good.
I gotta say, love these chips.
Yeah.
I got to score a bag of these.
Chesapeake Bay crab seasoning Lay's.
Uh-oh!
Yuelei: No?
Yeah, no, these are bad.
Put these at the bottom.
These are at my 7-Eleven.
Tomato-and-chili-flavored
chips, which sounds amazing.
I'm going to pronounce
this wrong. Sabritas?
Adobadas.
"Hecho en Mexico."
Oh, yeah, dude!
Not that spicy. They remind me kind of
a little bit like Takis.
Look how red this is.
Don't you think they'd be super spicy?
I like that.
These chip brands,
they're all going after
each other's throats.
It is really just like guerrilla warfare.
You guys don't understand what's going on
in our grocery stores in this country.
This is an uneasy mafia
alliance in Chip City.
No.
Because when it's thin like these,
it brings out the flavor more,
if that makes sense, and it's too strong.
It turns out if you put
Doritos Cool Ranch seasoning
on anything, it'll taste good.
Dill pickle.
So, I hate pickles.
Oof.
[groaning]
I hate them!
Put these at the bottom of every list.
I don't know what the
Flamin' Hot dill pickle chips
taste like, but the
regular dill pickle chips
are absolutely disgusting.
These sound phenomenal.
Flamin' Hot dill-pickle-flavored crisps.
Match made in heaven for me.
You get the heat, you get
that little bit of tang
to kind of cut through it.
If I could take one of these four
and have them in the UK
permanently, these ones.
One thing Walkers utilize a lot in the UK
are promotional flavors.
So currently what they've got going on
is one where they've partnered
with four different
restaurants from around the UK
to showcase some different cuisines.
So that means that we now have
fish-and-chip-flavored Walkers,
Madras-curry-flavored Walkers,
Thai-green-curry-flavored Walkers,
and chicken burrito Walkers.
At one point they made
a Cajun squirrel flavor.
I'm not making that up.
This one looks really
good. Thai green curry?
Think I'm gonna like this.
Yuck. Yuck!
Rank them down.
Fish and chips. OK.
I like fish and chips. Hang on.
It smells like cat food.
Now I can't stop thinking
about dry cat food.
All right. I like fish and chips.
This is the worst one.
This is so — [choking].
I'm gonna throw up.
Crown it. This is the
worst chip I've ever eaten,
the worst chip I've ever reviewed,
and this might be the worst
thing I've ever tasted.
Like, I feel like I'm on a prank show.
"We farted in a bag, gotcha!"
Like, oh, you know, like —
In the UK, Walkers has
a range of Baked crisps,
which I guess are marketed as
kind of like a healthier option.
These come in four flavors:
salt and vinegar, cheese and onion,
sour cream and onion, prawn cocktail.
We also have Baked potato chip options,
and one Baked flavor you can get here
you can't get it in the UK
is this, the barbecue Baked.
Besides the Baked,
there are also these
other healthier options
for Lay's potato chips fans.
It's known as the Better for
You range of potato chips,
and you can't get them in the UK.
You can get them here in
the US, including these,
the before-mentioned lightly salted chips.
Besides these, you can get
lightly salted barbecue,
wavy lightly salted,
Simply sea salt thick-cut,
and Simply barbecue thick-cut.
If you like crunchy chips,
Lay's also has you covered.
They have their Kettle Cooked series.
Here's four of the
flavors that I could find.
Original.
Flamin' Hot. You guys
want me to open these?
[laughing]
These are so red.
These win the reddest-chip award.
Look how red these are.
Like my eyes. Ahh!
I like the flavor of these,
but they're not very hot.
Oh, wait, yeah, they are. Ooh, yeah.
Oh, man, the Kettle Cooked jalapeño.
I think this whole kettle-chip thing
was just a ruse to go after Miss Vickie's.
Yep. They're, like, really similar.
And I love those Miss Vickie chips.
Sea salt and vinegar.
Sea salt and cracked pepper.
Other Kettle Cooked flavors
I could not get my hands on
include the mesquite
barbecue, the Maui onion —
oh, I would have loved those —
and, of course, the reduced-fat original.
Sorry.
We'll start with this one,
which is Max Punchy Paprika.
Now, I'm surprised you
guys don't have more
paprika-flavored crisps in the US,
'cause it's a really good flavor.
I like how they have a
"not actual size" warning on this bag,
just in case you thought that one crisp
was the size of your head as well.
Next up we've got Sizzling
Flame-Grilled Steak Max crisps.
Now, these ones I'm interested by.
These are Max crisps,
and they are double
crunch KFC Zinger flavor.
I think in the UK, we have a sort of
hot chicken sandwich at
KFC called a Zinger burger,
and supposedly these
are flavored like that.
Little Guy Fieri flames on the chip there.
Yeah, pretty good.
See, the flavor is not very strong,
but they're not kidding
on the double crunch.
This is like [crunching],
"I'm a man! I want to take
my crunching to the max!
Bleh!" Like, this is —
If the Zinger crisps somehow
weren't enough KFC for you,
then we also just have a kind of standard
KFC Max crisp as well.
The next one we have is this
Fiercely Flamin' Hot flavor.
Then we've got a few Max Strong crisps,
which I think are Walkers' attempt
to market to quite a specific demographic,
which is mostly male, a little bit older,
and kind of, like, the
blokey, laddie types.
And it says "perfect with
beer" underneath. Like ...
Putting the marketing to
one side for a second,
they come in three flavors,
which are hot chicken
wings, fiery peri-peri,
and jalapeño and cheese.
Then our final three Max
flavors are these three,
which are loaded cheddar and onion,
bold barbecue ribs,
and XXL chicken and chorizo flavored.
You can also get Lay's Wavy chips,
which is their shameless
rip-off of Ruffles.
And with Wavys, they come in flavors
of reduced-fat original;
original, which I think are these;
I brought the ranch!
Hickory barbecue, salt and
pepper, and lightly salted,
and one that I think is limited,
because it says on the bag.
Look what I found.
I don't even think
Harry knows I got these.
Carnitas street tacos Wavys.
Hell yes.
Whoa, smells good.
Oh, smells real good, actually.
Uh-oh. These aren't that good.
Trying to get flavored carnitas and onion
and cilantro and lime
all in a chip is very difficult.
Good effort, guys, good
attempt, but I mean ...
Next up we've got Sensations,
which is Walkers' range of
slightly more upmarket crisps.
They come with this very
sleek black packaging.
They have the kind of slightly
fancier flavor descriptions.
So, the classic Sensations
come in four flavors,
which are as follows:
got this one, which is
hickory-smoked cheddar and bacon.
This one, which is
roasted chicken and thyme,
personal favorite of mine.
And we've got this one,
which is balsamic vinegar
and caramelized onion.
And a firm crowd favorite on the end here,
which is Thai sweet chili Sensations.
Now, finally, Sensations also offer these
lime and coriander chutney Poppadoms.
Also in the US you can
get something called Stax,
which is this. It's not
so much, I don't think,
unique flavors, it's just
a different chip vessel.
Clearly, Lay's is going after Pringles.
I mean, they're all
going after each other.
These chip brands, man,
they are cutthroat.
Let's find out how good of a job
the Stax do
protecting their chips.
Did that really do that good of a job
protecting these chips?
They're still, some of them are broken.
Ooh, Buffalo wings with ranch. All right.
Xtra Flamin' Hot, Yuelei.
Ready to turn it up?
Surely you jest.
These are not spicy at all.
Whoa, major letdown.
That's Xtra Flamin' Hot,
and this is Flamas Xtreme.
But different colors, and
it's worded differently.
Jesus.
If you saw this color in the wild,
you're in trouble. Turn around and run.
Spicy Chile Limón.
It's like, how do we make our
chips worse on your palate
and worse for the environment?
Ta-da. Stax were born.
Avoid.
Other flavors I was not
able to get my hands on
by time of filming this: bacon
and cheddar potato skins,
mesquite barbecue, and Flamas.
Poppables, which is them
going after Doritos 3D,
and Doritos 3D was just
Doritos going after Bugles.
They got four flavors.
I got all four. I can't believe it.
Those flavors are sea salt,
sea salt and vinegar.
Yo, what's up?! Salty!
Honey barbecue.
White cheddar.
I don't want to try these at
all, but I feel like I should.
What is this?
It's like a little, like, chip pod.
What is the point of this?
I don't like Poppables.
We do have Stax in the UK,
but they're marketed under
the Doritos brand name
rather than the Walkers brand name.
We also used to have Poppables,
but it seems like they've
recently been discontinued.
That said, we do have a bunch
of other exclusive snacks
marketed under the Walkers brand name.
We'll start with Wotsits,
which I think are like
our equivalent of Cheetos.
We used to be able to
get Cheetos in the UK,
but then they got taken off the shelves.
Basically what we have are these, like,
baked cheesy puff snacks.
The standard flavor is cheese,
which is this blue one here,
but they also come in
the form of Flamin' Hot.
And you can get both flavors
either as a small version
or as a giant version.
Next up we've got Monster Munch,
which are these kind of
puffed corn, maize snacks
in the shape of a monster claw.
And you can get them flavored
with either pickled onion, roast beef,
or in Flamin' Hot,
which unfortunately I couldn't find today.
Just like Wotsits, you can get them
as the regular size or as the giant size.
Next up we've got Quavers.
These are kind of like a
thin, puffed curly snack,
and they usually come flavored with cheese
but are also available as salt and vinegar
or as prawn cocktail versions.
And then finally we have Squares.
Squares are these very thin,
as you can imagine, square-shaped crisps.
Very crunchy, usually quite
flavorful. I quite like those.
And they come in salt and vinegar,
cheese and onion, or ready salted.
Lay's also makes dips.
Creamy jalapeño, smooth ranch dip,
and, of course, French onion.
Yuelei says cheddar and sour cream.
Yeah, that's really good.
We also have a couple more crisp options
sold under the Walkers
brand name in the UK
which unfortunately we couldn't get today.
These include French
Fries, Bugles, and Mixups.
Are there any questionable ingredients
to look out for in your
Lay's and Walkers chips?
As far as the basic salted version
of Lay's chips go, we're fine.
Both in the US and the UK,
they are simply made up of
potatoes, vegetable oil, and salt.
But when you venture into other flavors,
things can get a little more interesting.
For example, in the UK,
several of our flavors
contain potassium chloride.
In normal doses, this is a perfectly safe
low-sodium alternative to salt.
However, it's also one
of the three ingredients
used in the three-drug
cocktail for lethal injections.
Enough potassium chloride in your system
will lead to an irregular
heartbeat and a cardiac arrest.
We don't have that in our USA Lay's,
but we do have caramel
color in our barbecue
and honey barbecue chips.
Ah, caramel color.
It is a widely used food coloring,
and it's also a controversial one.
Certain types of caramel
color can contain a byproduct
called 4-Me upper-case I. That's not an L.
Studies show that it caused
cancer in rats and mice,
leading to campaigns in support
of banning it in foods. Makes sense.
The FDA stopped short of banning it,
claiming that humans don't come
close to levels of exposure
that caused the rats' tumors.
Sounds like a challenge.
But that didn't stop
the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list
of chemicals, quote, "Known
to the state of California
to cause cancer or reproductive
toxicity," end quote.
Another fun thing to note
is that our smoky bacon
and roast chicken crisps
are actually both
suitable for vegetarians.
The flavoring is just
made up of other things
and doesn't include any meat extract.
Which country has the
least healthy crisps?
Let's compare the classic first.
A 28-gram bag of classic Lay's in the US
contains 160 calories.
If we scale up the UK's 25-gram bag
to account for that extra 3 grams,
28 grams of UK ready salted
would contain 147 calories.
So per gram, the UK's crisps
are healthier in every metric.
OK, fine,
but what about the least
healthy chip in each country?
Over here, a lot of them are tied
at 160 calories per 28-gram bag,
but we did find that of
the 160-calorie chips,
the highest fat content
are in the cheddar and sour cream.
Obviously the smaller bags.
That makes them the least healthy.
The least healthy crisps in the UK
are the Strong hot
chicken wings Max crisps.
28 grams of these would contain ...
Honestly, my main
takeaway from this is that
crisps might not be as unhealthy
as I thought they were.
You could eat, like, 10 multipack
bags of the ready salted,
and the only daily limit
you would have exceeded
would be your fat intake.
Yes, Harry, I believe that's
called death by deliciousness.
I live by the motto,
"Live fast, die fat, and
leave a salty corpse."
That's actually my LinkedIn headline.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Coca-Cola in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, regular Coke
comes in eight portion sizes,
starting with this mini can,
which is 150 milliliters.
Then we have three
options which all include
250 milliliters of Coke.
Then we have our standard
can, which is 330 milliliters.
Our standard plastic
bottle is 500 milliliters.
From there, we move up to
this bottle, which is 1 liter.
1.25 liters,
1.5 liters,
and 2.25 liters.
It's worth noting that
these ones are only stocked
by a limited number of
shops, including Iceland.
The supermarket chain, not the country.
And in the US, our classic
Coke comes in these sizes.
The mini can, which is 7.5 ounces.
Then this mini bottle, which is 8 ounces.
Then we jump up to the
standard 12-ounce can.
That also comes in a
little 12-ounce bottle.
From there, we got this guy,
which is the 16.9 fluid ounces,
aka 500 milliliters.
Then we have a 20-ounce bottle.
And finally, our biggest, the 2 liter,
which is also 67.6 ounces.
Now, that means as far as
Coca-Cola classic is concerned,
the UK's largest size
is actually 12.5% larger
than that in the US.
There is a reason why we're
specifying regular Coke here.
The UK government brought in a sugar tax,
which raised the price of sugary drinks
in an effort to reduce
people's sugar consumption.
Instead of raising the prices
of some of their drinks,
what Coca-Cola did was just to make
the sugary versions of their
drinks a little bit smaller.
For example, how the normal
largest size of regular Coke
is 1.5 liters,
whereas the largest size
of Coke Zero is 2 liters.
Whereas here in the US, we
don't have a specific sugar tax.
So we can get our bottles of
classic Coke and diet Coke
in the same size and for the same price.
As a consequence of the UK sugar rules,
it actually means that
the 2.25 regular Coke
isn't our largest bottle size.
That crown
[thud]
goes to this,
the 3-liter diet Coke bottle.
Now, this absolute unit is 50% larger
than the biggest bottle in America.
If you're doing, like, a party, maybe?
If you're buying that for yourself,
like, you've got a problem.
I'm sorry.
That is ridiculously huge
and really hilarious.
Now, I want to point
out that on Walmart.com,
they have this 3-liter
bottle of diet Coke on it,
but it's not available anywhere.
So my assumption is at one
point in the United States,
there was 3-liter bottles available.
But if Walmart doesn't have it,
I'm assuming it isn't anywhere.
That being said, in terms
of multipack options,
the US still comes out on top.
Our single largest multipack
is the 35-pack of 12-ounce cans.
Let's get a picture of that on the screen.
I ordered it online, and
here's what they sent me.
24-pack, and nine loose cans.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong,
but what's 24 plus nine?
It ain't 35.
And when I emailed the
place that I bought it from,
they said, "Oh, sorry,
you're missing two cans,
so we'll just refund you the two cans."
And I'm like, "No, I
don't want the two cans,
I want the 35-pack
'cause that's what I'm
doing for this video,"
and they just sent me $2
back, so thank you for that.
Anyway, so then I go, nuts to this.
I'm going to Walmart.com.
Give me the 35-pack.
Buy. Enter.
And then they sent me
three 12-packs, which
is more than 35 cans,
so I guess technically
they're being generous,
but once again, it's not
that I need 35 cans of soda.
I need the 35-can pack for
this video specifically.
There's a 35-can pack
somewhere in America,
and everyone's just sending
me roughly 35 cans of soda.
Thank you for that.
Our largest single item is this.
This is a 24-pack of 330-milliliter cans,
which comes to a total of 7.92 liters.
Here is everything that's in regular Coke.
Harry: Carbonated water.
Joe: Carbonated water.
Harry: Sugar.
Joe: High-fructose corn syrup.
Harry: Color (caramel E150d).
Joe: Caramel color.
Harry: Phosphoric acid.
Joe: Phosphoric acid.
Harry: And natural flavorings,
Joe: And natural flavors.
Harry: including caffeine.
Joe: Caffeine.
Now, obviously we don't get
a full ingredients list,
because the recipe of Coca-Cola
is a closely guarded secret.
At the World of Coca-Cola in Atlanta,
there's reportedly a vault which
contains the secret formula
written down on a piece of paper.
Who cares if the recipe gets loose?
Coca-Cola, no one's gonna edge you up.
Pepsi can't beat you.
Who cares?
I mean, how do you even make cola?
You probably just go into the factory
and eyeball it and figure it out.
It's not super famous because
you don't know how to make it,
it's super famous because
they edged everybody out.
You won.
Do you – I don't care.
Do you want the recipe?
I couldn't care less.
So, what do we know about the recipe?
Well, there is one obvious difference,
and that's the use of
high-fructose corn syrup in the US
versus the use of sugar in the UK.
Corn syrup is everywhere in American food.
It's cheaper for manufacturers to use
because the government gives
subsidies to corn farmers,
keeping the corn supply
high and the prices low.
Should you be worried about consuming
high-fructose corn syrup?
The short answer is not really.
Some studies have suggested
that the negative effects of sugar
tend to come from fructose
rather than from glucose,
but the high fructose in
high-fructose corn syrup
only relates to its fructose content
in relation to other corn syrups.
It actually still has less fructose
than table sugar or than honey.
The main difference it
causes might be the taste.
You've heard Americans
talk about Mexican Coke.
You can find it in most
Mexican restaurants
and in some grocery stores
next to the regular Coke
in the glass bottle.
Mexican Coke is made with cane sugar;
our regular Coke is made with
high-fructose corn syrup.
People tend to like the Mexican Coke more
because it has a sweeter sugary taste.
So right now to compare and contrast,
I'm going to do a blind taste test
of both American Coke and Mexican Coke.
Hang on.
And Harry was nice enough to send me
a United Kingdom Coke.
I've also got some British
Coke, some Mexican Coke,
and some American Coke.
I'm now going to blindfold myself
and let our camera operator, Sarah,
pour the Cokes out for me.
I'm blindfolded. I don't
know which one's which.
I'm going to try them one after the other
and try and figure out which one's which.
I'm going to start on the right.
Hm. See, it could just be mind games,
but that doesn't taste like
exactly what I'm used to.
No. 2.
Ooh. OK. That one tastes pretty good.
No. 3.
These two taste pretty similar.
This one tastes a bit
weird for some reason.
I'm going to guess that this
one is American, on the right.
I was expecting more of a
difference, I'll be honest.
I'll go with British in the
middle, Mexican on my left.
Put them in front of me, and
then I'll unblindfold myself.
Wow. OK.
That was Mexican Coke.
I was right about British.
I just got Mexican and
American Coke mixed up.
Wow. OK.
A lot of people have really
hyped up Mexican Coke to me,
and I honestly, like,
that was my least favorite of the three.
They taste exactly the same.
So I'm going to go UK, Mexico, USA.
Wow, really?
["America the Beautiful" plays]
I'm so great at pointless things!
Any other ingredients to look out for?
Well, one of them might be caramel color.
As we know, certain
classes of caramel color
have a byproduct which has
been linked to causing cancer.
Unfortunately, the caramel E150d
that Coke in the UK uses
is one of these classes.
We reached out to Coca-Cola here in the US
to see if that was the case,
because the type is not
specified on the label.
They told us that it is in fact
the same E150d caramel
color in the States.
But what about diet Coke?
It still contains caramel color,
but instead of using sugar
and corn syrup to sweeten it,
in the US it's sweetened with aspartame,
and in the UK it's
sweetened with aspartame
as well acesulfame K.
The good news is that both
the EU and the FDA say
that acesulfame K is safe for consumption.
In terms of the difference with Coke Zero,
in the US, our Coke Zero uses
ace K as well as aspartame.
Rumors have existed for years claiming
that aspartame causes cancer,
but it turns out that that
is likely to be false.
The claims originated from
some Italian researchers
way back in 2005.
I feel like I heard about
that in the '80s, but OK.
People were quick to call their methods
and results into question.
The FDA says, "the use of aspartame
as a general ... sweetener ... is safe."
While the European Food
Safety Authority says,
"Studies do not suggest an increased risk
associated with the aspartame consumption
for ... leukemia, brain tumours
or a variety of cancers."
There's a cool side effect for Coke
using these artificial sweeteners
you might not know about.
Because they're so much more
sweet than sugar per pound,
there's a tiny amount of them
dissolved in your diet Coke
compared to the amount of
sugar that's in a classic Coke.
That means a can of Coke is
denser than that of a diet Coke.
So when you put said Coke in water ...
to the bottom.
Diet Coke ...
floats.
One other rumor we felt
compelled to address
was the role of cocaine in Coca-Cola.
This dates right back to the 1800s
when the drink was invented.
Coca-Cola's official stance on this
is that there's never been
cocaine in any of its products.
What it does seem to contain,
however, is coca extract.
Coca is the plant from
which cocaine is extracted.
Fluid extract of coca was
one of the ingredients
in a list "This American Life" discovered
which was reportedly a recipe
for an early version of Coca-Cola.
And it seems like they're still using it.
In 1988, a Coca-Cola spokesperson said,
"Ingredients from the coca leaf are used,
but there is no cocaine in it
and it all is being tightly overseen
by regulatory authorities."
What's fun is that Coca-Cola
got a specific exemption
from the United Nations
in order to keep using
coca extract as an ingredient.
Specifically, Article 27
of the Single Convention
on Narcotic Drugs of 1961.
There's only one facility in the US
licensed to import and process coca leaves
through a special deal with the DEA.
It is owned by the Stepan Company,
and it's in Maywood, New Jersey.
According to the Peruvian officials,
they buy around 100 metric tons
of dried Peruvian coca leaves each year.
They reportedly process
them and de-cocanize them,
taking all of the cocaine out of them.
The cocaine is sold to hospitals
for use as an anesthetic,
and the cocaine-free extract
is then sent to Coca-Cola
for use in their products.
Coca-Cola's official line
on the subject is, quote,
"Coca-Cola does not contain cocaine
or any other harmful substance,
and cocaine has never been
an added ingredient in Coca-Cola."
End quote.
But it's fair to say that
cocaine and coca extract
are not the same thing.
So the latter might in fact be
one of their not-so-secret
secret ingredients.
Here are all the Coca-Cola
products in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here's all the Coca-Cola
items you'll find in the US
that you cannot find in the UK.
I want to start with two exclusive flavors
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
They're these two right here,
cherry vanilla and orange vanilla.
Cherry vanilla seems pretty standard.
I think I've had this a bunch of times.
It's great. It's refreshing. I enjoy it.
We can't get cherry vanilla in the UK,
but we can get cherry
and we can get vanilla,
so I guess I can make my own.
Oh, God. Ah!
[exhales]
Panic over.
The smart thing to do would
be to mix these in a glass,
but I'm not a smart man.
Ah.
Pretty good.
The only exclusive Coke
flavor we can currently get –
[coughs] sorry.
The only exclusive Coke
flavor we can currently get
in the UK is this one, which
is diet Coke Sublime Lime.
As the name suggests,
it's just diet Coke flavored with lime.
Next up, caffeine-free Coca-Cola,
not to be confused with
caffeine-free diet Coke,
which is what you guys
have over there in the UK.
Apparently that's your
only caffeine-free option?
For shame.
This one is delicious.
It actually tastes just like Coke.
It's perfect for after 2 p.m.
when you want to keep
drinking soda, like me.
But if you like caffeine
and you want a little bit of a boost,
Coke Energy I believe is
available in both countries,
but one exclusive Coke Energy flavor
you can't get in the UK is this.
The Coke Energy zero sugar.
The Coke Energy drinks
are being phased out.
I can't imagine why.
I think they're actually really good.
In fact, I went ahead
and got the other ones.
Regular. I don't really like zero sugar,
but I do like just regular.
Oh, yeah.
I'm into that.
Yeah, thank you.
It's good. I mean, like ...
energy meter's going up, Yuelei!
Going up!
If you're like me and
you love soda and coffee,
Coke in the US has you covered with these.
You got caramel, vanilla,
vanilla no sugar,
dark blend, and dark blend zero sugar.
Oh, my God, I sincerely
love these so much.
Zero sugar can go there.
Ooh, which one do I want?
Hits the spot.
The I-want-to-jack-my-caffeine-levels-
through-the-roof spot.
Dude, Coke and coffee's good together.
Has anyone had two of
these at the same time?
I don't think they have.
They don't mix very well.
But individually they're great.
Uh-oh.
I might have overdone it.
We don't have Coke coffees in the UK.
However, Coca-Cola owns Costa Coffee,
which is a coffee chain in the UK,
and they produce canned coffees.
So I guess, again, I
can try and make my own.
So, the issue here is
they do do Americanos,
but I got latte instead.
So see how well milk
combines with Coke, I guess.
Yeah. Um. [laughs]
Regretting quite a lot
of things right now.
Namely all the life choices
that led me to this point.
Cheers.
Nope.
Not even a little bit.
No, no, no.
Don't do that.
No one else do that.
Please, God. Ugh.
Just like really watery, fizzy coffee
that is kind of sweet and ... ugh.
No. Bad.
The final exclusive
range in the UK is this,
Coca-Cola signature mixers.
Coca-Cola worked with bartenders
to design special Cokes
with different flavors
which are designed to
be used in cocktails.
These come with smoky notes, spicy notes,
herbal notes, and woody notes.
Tag yourself. I am spicy notes.
Cool.
[rumbling]
My stomach is making some weird
noises after drinking that.
No one else do that, please, God. Ugh!
Apparently these are
designed to be enjoyed
with premium dark spirits.
Now, I know nothing about
mixology, but thankfully,
a bartender friend from Australia
came through with a recipe.
So now I'm going to use
the smoky notes Coca-Cola
to put a "Food Wars" twist
on a Jack's godfather highball.
Cocktail Time.
Slight hiccup.
Don't have a bottle opener.
This is either going to work
or I'm going to break my keys
and be locked out of my house.
Improvisation.
Slash.
Alcoholism.
Ooh, it does smell quite smoky.
Harry was kind enough to send me this,
so now I have one as well.
It just says, "Pour ingredients
into an ice-filled glass."
Formally apologize to
any actual bartenders
who are watching this while
I butcher your profession.
30 milliliters of
Tennessee whiskey we have,
and then 20 milliliters of Disaronno.
A delightful smoky Coke.
Next we mix together.
And there you have it. Thanks to Coke,
we've put our own spin on a
Jack's godfather highball.
Cheers.
Ooh. That's delicious.
Um, yeah, I'm not going
to make that drink,
'cause I don't have all that stuff.
So I'm going to go ahead
and make a Joe highball.
First, get yourself the
biggest glass available.
Step two: no ice.
Find yourself some whiskey.
Cheers, my man.
Oh, man.
What is in this?
If I was to do it again,
I'd use less of this.
It's iced tea, guys.
I'm not gonna f---ing drink whiskey
this early in the morning.
You know what it tastes like?
Flat Coke.
Oh, man, I'm getting a headache though.
Last but not least, in the
US, you have the option
to order customized Coke bottles.
Check out the one I made.
Joe and Harry.
Here's everything that's
in a 500-milliliter bottle
of Coca-Cola in the UK.
And here's everything in that same bottle
of classic Coke in the US.
That means that the UK's version
actually has slightly more
calories in it than the US.
Joe: And we have more sugar.
And for some reason, our Coke
has a little bit of sodium,
while the UK seems to have none.
Obviously, the main thing to
look out for here is the sugar.
500 milliliters in both the US and the UK
contains over 100% of
your daily allowance.
53 grams of sugar. [laughs]
It does put it in perspective, doesn't it?
You never see it laid out like that,
but that is how much sugar is in Coke.
And I drink a lot of Coke.
That's concerning.
It's also worth noting that both countries
put the same amount of
caffeine in their Coke.
For reference, the average
cup of filtered coffee
contains about 96 milligrams of caffeine.
So that's exactly double the
amount in this bottle of Coke.
Interestingly, diet Coke is
actually more caffeinated
than regular Coke.
There's 63 milligrams in this bottle,
which is a 30% increase.
And it makes sense, 'cause
our Coke with coffee
contains 69 milligrams of
caffeine per 12 fluid ounces.
If you do the math to find
out the figure per ounce,
it's double the caffeine
of a regular Coke.
But the real caffeine king
is my boy Coke Energy.
Mm.
Whether you get the classic or the cherry,
the 12-ounce can contains
114 milligrams of caffeine,
which is triple the caffeine content
of a regular Coke per ounce.
Yo, don't I know it.
From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Popeyes in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
The fountain drinks at
Popeyes come in three sizes.
The small, which is 22 ounces,
the medium, which is 30 ounces,
and the large, which is,
of course, 40 ounces.
40 ounces.
That's so much soda.
In the UK, drinks only come in two sizes,
as a kids size or as a regular size.
We're not sure how much
is in either of these,
so we're going to measure them both.
A little over 300.
About 450.
But those aren't the biggest, I say!
Actually, at the Popeyes in the US,
you can also get a gallon of sweet tea
and unsweetened tea.
One whole gallon.
Ah, look at this!
Gallon, gallon.
Oh, and don't you hate
when dummies do that thing
where they're like,
"Hey, the medium is the
same size as the large!"
And it never is, it's a total con, so.
Medium soda, large cup.
Oh, wow, guys!
The medium's about the
same size as the large,
except for, like, oh, I
don't know, 10 ounces!
Dumb TikTokers. You guys aren't even ...
out-of-your-league TikTokers.
I'm the fast-food king online! All right?
When was this cleaned last?
Ooh,
I'm gonna go 36. What do you think?
I mean, it could have been
the amount to top of this cup,
but again, you can't
fill this to the brim.
You have to put a cap on it.
In the UK, fries just
come as a regular serving.
US, we got two Popeyes fries sizes,
a regular and a large.
The regular, as we have here,
just came with the side of
the three-piece we got here,
and of course a large,
which is a box of just fries.
Harry: We're going to weigh these to see
how they compare to the US.
Joe: We, of course, now are going to also
weigh our largest fry.
Do not sleep on these fries.
You'll be surprised to learn
that the inside of this
scale is disgusting.
A Popeyes chicken sandwich in the UK
weighs exactly 250 grams.
Joe: In the US, it weighs
270 grams.
In the US, Popeyes signature chicken
comes in seven serving sizes.
We'll start with these.
So, of course, the one-piece kids meal,
then you can upgrade to
a two-piece regular meal,
which comes with a side and a biscuit,
or you can get yourself the three-piece,
and a four-piece. Side and a biscuit.
From there, you can get yourself
an eight-piece family meal,
the 12-piece for the family as well,
or just for one person over a weekend,
and the largest, the 16-piece.
Are you kidding me?
[laughs]
How absurd is this? Look
at all this chicken.
In the UK, the signature chicken comes
as a two-piece meal,
as a three-piece meal,
as a six-piece sharer,
as a nine-piece sharer,
or our largest size, the 12-piece sharer.
Let's weigh a wing, a thigh, and a leg
to see whose chickens are bigger.
So, in the UK, our thigh,
leg, and wing combo
came to around 290 grams.
Here we go. First guy up, the leg.
Next up, got that wing.
Kind of a wimpy-looking one.
And this one, the thigh.
How 'bout the tendies?
In the US, we have these following sizes:
A kids meal has a one-piece,
but what's up? They gave us two!
And then from there you get a three-piece,
which they forgot,
and then we have five-piece,
comes with a side and a biscuit,
eight pieces.
I feel like they're getting
bigger as I go along.
Look at the size of this tender.
Then we have the 12-piece.
I mean, guys, this is like a --
look at this!
Did you know they're this big?
This is fantastic. I
love how big these are.
That's what I'm talking
about, Popeyes! Thank you.
And, of course, the 16-piece.
Look at this bad boy.
Look at the size of these guys.
Tenders in the UK come
in four portion sizes,
as a two-piece, which is the kids meal,
as a three-piece, a
five-piece, and an eight-piece.
Next up is the nuggets.
These can be found in servings of
a four-piece kids meal,
a six-piece kids meal,
eight-piece,
the 12-piece,
24-piece,
36 pieces,
and then this double pile right here,
the biggest order, 48 pieces.
And I have to say, does
not look like enough.
I know I could destroy that
48-piece with confidence.
What do we got here?
Oh, look at this sticker! This is fun.
Yeah, look at these guys!
Look at this big one playing a saxophone,
how fun is that?
That's cool, right?
In the UK, we actually
call our nuggets bites,
and they come in the following sizes:
There's a four-piece,
which is a kids meal,
a six-piece, a nine-piece, and a 12-piece.
Unfortunately, we
couldn't get these today.
USA, we got biscuits, baby.
These are the not-cookie biscuits
that have come up before in
other "Food Wars" episodes.
These are the biscuits biscuits,
and at Popeyes, you can get them in one,
either on its own or probably
with just about every meal.
You can also get them in six.
It's, like, rolling right down here.
And you can also get them in 12.
Just overflowing biscuits over here.
We actually do have biscuits
on the UK Popeyes menu.
If you order it as a
side, you get one biscuit.
The biggest single item you
can get on the US Popeyes menu
is this, the Bigger Family Feast.
It comes with 12 pieces of chicken,
five chicken sandwiches,
two large sides, got the
slaw and the mashed potatoes,
five biscuits, and five apple pies.
This entire thing will set
you back about 60 bucks
and clocks in at 10,000 calories
if you choose a more calorific
side, like the fries.
I did not.
That pretty much dwarfs
our largest single item,
which is this, the 12-piece sharer.
You get 12 pieces of
chicken, four regular sides,
four biscuits, and four drinks,
all for the price of
24 pounds and 95 pence,
which was around $33.50
at the time of recording.
Mm.
We're so bad at fried chicken in the UK.
We just don't do it well.
But this, I gotta say,
I feel like a certain Kentucky-based chain
has had the monopoly for far too long,
and they've let their standards slip.
So this is really good.
I'm thrilled that the standards
are hopefully going to get raised.
And here's everything you
can find at a US Popeyes
you won't find in the UK.
And here are most of
the things you'll find
at a UK Popeyes that you
won't find in the US.
Let's start with the chicken.
There are two main exclusive
chicken options in the UK.
Firstly in the UK, we can get
a chicken sandwich deluxe.
It's just a Popeyes chicken sandwich,
but there's cheese and
lettuce on here as well.
What he means to say
is they took a delicious chicken sandwich
and added a bunch of junk.
Deluxe means vegetables,
aka the junk I don't want on
my crispy chicken sandwich.
Popeyes in the UK also sell hot wings.
These come in orders of
three, five, eight, 12, or 20.
Now, it might surprise
some American viewers,
but London in particular
has a pretty big chicken-shop culture,
and we're pretty passionate
about our hot wings,
so let's see how these measure up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't get it twisted.
We're the wings country,
and we should have those.
I have no idea why we don't have those.
That to me is a very good chicken wing.
Good level of heat, very
crispy on the outside,
very juicy on the inside,
what more can you want?
We only have one exclusive chicken item.
Well, it's technically not an item,
it's more of a style of chicken.
Both in the US and the UK,
they have the spicy and
they have the regular,
but we also have something
called the blackened chicken.
It is a chicken option without breading,
therefore, who cares?
And it comes in the form
of sandwich or tenders.
Here it is, blackened chicken.
It's called fried chicken for a reason.
This is just, like, cooked on a grill?
Grilled chicken at Popeyes.
What is wrong with you?
Oh.
Nope.
In both the UK and the US,
Popeyes chicken sandwiches,
fried chicken, and chicken tenders
are available as either classic or spicy.
One interesting fact is that
someone from Popeyes told us
that the UK version of the spicy chicken
is actually hotter than it is in America,
after they tried it on some focus groups
and they kept asking them
to crank up the heat.
Who said British people
can't handle spices, huh?
Now, this is not an exclusive
because it's available in both countries.
However, this is my first time
trying an American-style biscuit.
Now, the obvious statement is that, to me,
this just looks like a scone.
The color is there, the shape is there,
the kind of flaky layers are there.
It even kind of smells like a scone.
And the fact that this is
being served with fried chicken
to me and to I think most
British people is really weird.
Don't get me wrong, this is tasty,
I'm just still struggling
to see any differences
between this and a British scone.
Popeyes in the US doesn't
just serve chicken,
it also has seafood,
something you can't
find in the UK Popeyes.
Now, the US Popeyes did for a while
have a Cajun flounder sandwich,
which is a fried flounder fillet in a bun
with some pickles and tartar sauce.
At the recording of this,
it is no longer available.
I don't know if it was
a limited-time thing
or they just stopped, they're
taking a break, I don't know.
But you can still get the popcorn shrimp.
This is it.
And it comes in a quarter-pound serving.
There are no seafood options in the UK,
but we do have one vegan option
which you guys don't have in the US,
and that's the Creole red bean sandwich.
This is a 100% plant-based red bean patty
with some tomato, some
lettuce, and a Creole sauce,
but unfortunately we weren't
able to get one today.
I will say the Popeyes menu in the US
doesn't look very vegetarian-friendly,
so maybe if this takes off in the UK,
you guys can get it too.
Whatever the hell that thing is,
100% plant-based red bean pat -- ugh.
That will never touch American shores.
That can stay in the UK.
No one's going to Popeyes for
vegetarian, vegan anything.
It's a fried-chicken place. So no.
Now, we have two sides that
are exclusive to the US.
Red beans and rice.
Grr!
Oh, do we got a bad boy? A thingy-thing?
Did they not give us any silverware?
Mystery spoon from somewhere
in the office, all right.
Red beans and rice, there it is.
And coleslaw.
We just have the one
exclusive side in the UK,
and it's onion rings.
These are battered using buttermilk,
similarly to the chicken.
Unfortunately, we weren't able
to get these today either.
I got a bunch of sauces in front of me,
and you know what that means! It's:
Sauce Talk.
We've got a tartar sauce.
The Creole cocktail sauce.
Creole is a type of cuisine in Louisiana.
Blackened ranch.
Was this supposed to be
for the blackened chicken,
do you think?
And of course we have
regular buttermilk ranch.
Well, we already know what ranch is.
Ranchy.
Blackened ranch.
Oh, that's way better.
The sweet heat.
Had this earlier with the tenders,
can confirm, fantastic sauce.
Wild honey mustard
and the bayou Buffalo sauce.
In the UK, we have the
following exclusive sauces:
we have this voodoo sweet chili sauce,
which could be quite similar
to the US's sweet heat sauce.
Then we have a garlic mayo
as well as a mango habanero sauce,
which sounds really good.
It's not an exclusive,
but shout-out to the Mardi Gras mustard,
because this stuff slaps.
Now, it's not exactly an exclusive,
but it's worth a shout-out.
Musician Megan Thee Stallion
recently launched a collab with Popeyes
and released the Hottie Sauce.
You can get it as a side for dip
or pre-add it to your chicken sandwich.
Or if you're in the UK,
you can dip a hot wing
into the Hottie Sauce
and have a hot wing summer.
She's also becoming a Popeyes franchisee,
as she is opening her own Popeyes soon.
And then underneath this, it says,
"Need some 'WAP' content
here, open to ideas."
I'm assuming she is the
one who did the song "WAP"?
I don't know who this person is.
I've never heard "WAP."
I just know it as a
reference on the internet.
And I am going to bask in the glory
that only some my age can,
of not having any idea
what a popular thing is.
Ah.
Desserts!
This is a cinnamon apple pie.
Oh, my God [mumbles].
What?
And ...
ugh!
Chocolate chip cookies.
Was she with Paul Davis,
Pete Davidson for
awhile? Was that the one?
We have an exclusive
dessert option of our own,
which is ice cream sundaes.
Now, these are available
in the following flavors:
vanilla, chocolate, caramel,
with Oreos, or with Lotus Biscoff.
You can also pay an extra 50 pence
to add little pieces of Oreo or Biscoff
to any of these sundaes.
If you've watched "Food
Wars" for long enough,
you'll know that I really
don't like Biscoff,
and I know that's a very
controversial opinion,
so don't send for me, please.
All right, so before you saw
those big gallons of tea.
There was sweet tea and
unsweetened tea. Very nice.
We also have a premium lemonade.
That's this right here.
I've been sipping on because
this chicken is getting to me.
They also have premium
strawberry lemonade,
and they also have this
right here, Hawaiian Punch.
You guys don't know
what Hawaiian Punch is?
It is fruit punch.
Oh, yeah, all the good
stuff's at the bottom.
And ginger ale. Ugh, I have
a headache all of a sudden.
We have a range of
exclusive drinks in the UK,
some of which are hot and
some of which are cold.
We'll start with the hot drinks.
It wouldn't be a British fast-food menu
unless you could get a cup of tea.
Then we have a range of hot coffees,
including a cappuccino, an Americano,
a flat white, and a latte.
Then we're on to the cold drinks,
including some bottled options,
like this Oasis summer fruits,
this sparkling water, and
this orange Capri Sun.
Of all the linguistic differences
between the States and the UK,
this might be the one
that annoys me the most.
We pronounce this CAP-ri Sun.
You pronounce it Cap-RI Sun.
You're putting the emphasis
on the completely wrong part
of the word. Get it right.
In the UK, you can also get a range
of hand-spun milkshakes,
which unfortunately we couldn't get today.
When they are available,
you can get them in similar
flavors to the sundaes.
They come as Biscoff,
Oreo, vanilla, chocolate,
caramel, or also strawberry.
And just like the sundaes,
you can pay an additional 50 pence
for an additional Biscoff or Oreo topping.
The chicken sandwich from a UK Popeyes
contains the following.
If you get the chicken
sandwich at a US Popeyes,
it contains this.
What if you made it a meal?
You add the regular serving
of Popeyes Cajun fries,
you'll be adding the following.
A side of fries in the UK
contains the following.
Poof!
Add this medium Coke to the mix,
and you're adding 368 calories,
99 carbs, all of those are sugar,
and 88 milligrams of sodium.
And a regular Coke in
the UK adds 180 calories,
zero grams of fat or saturated fat,
45.6 grams of carbs,
all of which are sugars,
and zero sodium.
And what is the total of this US meal?
1,335 calories,
56 grams of total fat,
19 of those grams are saturated fat,
182 grams of carbs,
106.5 of those grams of sugar,
and 2,118 milligrams of sodium.
Yo.
The UK total:
1,300 calories,
63.7 grams of fat,
of which 20.4 grams of saturated,
135.4 grams of carbs,
of which 54.8 grams are sugars,
and 1,160 milligrams of sodium.
Obviously the sugar stats here look bad,
but in Popeyes' defense,
a majority of the sugar is coming from
this 30 ounces -- [chuckles] 30 ounces --
of Coca-Cola.
Now, if you got a sugar-free soda instead,
it would be a much lower figure.
The meal does contain, however,
95% of your daily saturated fat
as well as 92% of your daily sodium.
Perhaps surprisingly, it seems as if
the fat and saturated fat totals
are actually higher in the
UK than they are in the US.
This meal would take you just over 100%
of your daily saturated fat allowance.
However, the sodium
content is way higher here
than it is in the UK.
The biggest difference comes
in the chicken sandwich.
This guy right here, for some reason,
has 260% more sodium than that in the UK.
Unfortunately, Popeyes has not disclosed
a full ingredients list
in the US, only allergens.
It's a similar deal in the UK.
Popeyes doesn't disclose
a full ingredients list,
just allergens.
The only sort of surprising
thing we found out in the US
is that there is fish present
in the beans and rice.
But what else do we know
about the Popeyes food?
Ah!
Well, for one, on the website,
there is a list of a
slightly vague commitment
to removing all artificial
colors, flavors,
and preservatives from their fried chicken
by the end of 2022.
So, that's this year,
guys. Better get on it.
Also by the end of this year,
they want to remove all
MSG from their chicken.
Now, correct me if I'm wrong,
but that implies they currently
are using MSG on the chicken.
But how much and to which chicken dishes
they're actually adding MSG,
they have not specified.
They also want to use only cage-free eggs
by the end of 2025.
Take your time there, guys, jeez.
Also, cage-free "eggs"?
What about the chickens?
One interesting thing is that in the UK,
Popeyes has pledged to
make all its chicken halal,
meaning it's suitable
for Muslim people to eat.
Popeyes UK also uses Red
Tractor-assured chicken.
This is a farming standards board
which oversees poultry farming in the UK.
To be Red Tractor-assured,
you can't do things like
wash your chicken in chlorine
or use antibiotics on your chicken,
unless it's approved by a vet
to treat a specific illness.
Red Tractor doesn't exist in the US,
but Popeyes does say it uses chicken
free from added hormones and steroids.
There's a commitment on Popeyes' website
to removing antibiotics from its chickens
by the end of 2021.
So that's right around the corner
at the time of recording this,
and we reached out to them
for what was going on,
and they told us X, [laughs]
which is code for nothing.
Red Tractor certification also means
that chickens must be kept
in a safe, comfortable,
hygienic, and sufficiently sized housing;
given a full, healthy diet;
and have permanent access
to environmental enrichment
that is suitable for their needs.
Again, we do not have
Red Tractor in the US,
but Popeyes claims it wants to, quote,
"promote practices that support
and address the globally recognized
five freedoms of animal
welfare," end quote.
These principles broadly line up
with the Red Tractor
guarantees, which are:
freedom from hunger and thirst,
freedom from discomfort,
freedom from pain, injury, and disease,
freedom to express
normal, natural behaviors,
like accommodating for
chickens' instinct to roost,
and freedom from fear and distress.
I don't even get those freedoms!
I'm terrified all the time!
[chicken clucks]
So it looks like they're aiming
for equivalent standards,
even if they don't have
a nice Red Tractor badge
or whatever to prove
that they've achieved it.
Now, obviously Popeyes is a
Louisiana fast-food chain.
Joe asked me to try and
find Louisiana on a map.
I don't know much about
American geography.
I can tell you where California is,
where Texas is, where Florida is.
New York is somewhere over here, I think.
If I had to hazard a guess
as to where Louisiana was,
I mean, it's the South, right?
It's the South.
Maybe ...
is it, like, this one?
Maybe that one there.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between M&M's in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in the US, we have eight
different portion sizes of M&M's.
All the way at the end here,
the smallest portion is
known as the fun size.
This little guy is 0.6
ounces, or 18 grams.
Then, single size bag, 1.69 ounces.
Then we go up to the box.
This is 3.1 ounces, or 87 grams.
Now we have the share size.
Peanut makes its first appearance.
This is 3.27 ounces, or 92.7 grams.
Little bigger of a pouch,
we have the 10.7-ounce, or 303-gram,
sharing-size pouch part two.
Then we jump up to the family size.
This is 19.2 ounces, 545 grams.
Throwing a party? M&M's got you covered.
This is the party pack.
38 ounces, 1,105 grams.
And the biggest portion
size you can get is this,
the pantry-size tub.
62 ounces, 1,757 grams.
In the UK, M&M's come in
four standard portion sizes.
Around the holidays, you
can get a selection box
with a small packet of
M&M's that weighs 45 grams,
but unfortunately, we
couldn't get one today.
Our standard pouch is 125 grams.
Then we move up to a more-to-share bag,
which, for standard chocolate
M&M's, comes with 250 grams.
The largest size available
in the UK is a party bag.
I went to about eight
different supermarkets
and I couldn't find one,
but usually they would
contain 1 kilogram of M&M's,
so we're going to make our own.
There is our unofficial party-size bag.
1 kilogram of M&M's.
All said, America's largest size
is 75.7% larger than the UK's.
In the UK, the portion
sizes also vary slightly
depending on which flavor
of M&M's you've opted for.
A more-to-share bag of
chocolate M&M's is 250 grams,
but a more-to-share bag of
crispy M&M's is just 246 grams.
If you want the most value in the UK,
opt for peanut M&M's.
A more-to-share bag of
those contains 268 grams.
Are the M&M's themselves different sizes
in the UK and the US?
We're going to weigh out
100 grams of chocolate M&M's
and count them to see how many you get.
One, two, three ...
Two, three, four, five ...
[fast-forwarding]
That is so annoying!
It was so close to being 100 grams
of exactly 100 M&M's,
but instead 100 grams
of UK chocolate M&M's
is 102 M&M's.
100 grams of American M&M's
is 114 M&M's.
So what does that mean, ours are smaller?
And how do we feel about that?
I don't know if it's better or worse.
But portion size don't stop there.
You can also buy M&M's
directly from the M&M website.
The main purpose of this seems to be
catering for large events
like weddings or parties.
You can technically get
smaller-than-average portion sizes,
but only in bulk quantities.
For example, in the US, you can get these.
Tiny party-favor packs of M&M's
weighing just 0.75 ounces each.
Or they have party-favor tins,
which contain 1.5 ounces of M&M's.
But both of these have to have a minimum
of 20 or more units.
Now, what doesn't require a minimum order,
however, are the bulk bags.
In the US you can order bulk bags
of 1 pound, 2 pounds, or 5 pounds.
Now, technically, you could
order 10 pounds of M&M's,
but they just send you two 5-pound bags,
which is a bit disappointing,
so we just got one.
5-pounder.
Look at these M&M's.
The UK website is a similar situation.
Our smallest portion size is
this 28-gram designer case.
But the minimum order for these is 20.
Unlike the US, we only
have one bulk-bag order.
And that's this one,
which is 1.5 kilograms.
That's around 3.3 pounds,
which is a 34% decrease
from the largest single
bag size in the US.
If you do order M&M's on the website,
you can customize them.
We chose some custom colors
and also put some custom
text on the M&M's.
In terms of colors, I went for this
lovely blue-and-white color scheme
to match my stunning M&M's T-shirt.
Then I had some fun putting
some text options on there.
Firstly, I went for "Harry <3 Joe."
We also had to rep the show,
so I put a "Food Wars" one on there.
Then, because I have the mind of a child,
I tried to put some
swear words on the M&M's,
and it turns out they
actually try and censor you.
For example, if you try and
put the word "poop" on an M&M,
a warning message will flash up
telling you to get in touch with the team.
But there is a work-around.
For example, for the word "poop,"
by replacing the O's with 0s,
I was able to get around the censorship
and create poop M&M's.
The same goes for replacing
the I with a 1 in "penis"
and replacing the A with a 4 in "balls."
This is some serious journalism
taking place right here.
Now, Harry, of course,
went with customizing M&M's
with fun words and stuff on it.
I just went for pictures.
You can get custom images on an M&M.
So what I did is I got
Harry face and Joe face M&M's.
OK, that'll show 'em.
Here are all the ingredients
in chocolate M&M's in the UK.
And here is everything in a bag
of classic M&M's in the US.
Look at all those colors.
A few things to note here.
Firstly, the food colorings used
in the two countries are wildly different.
In the UK, some of our colors are natural,
including the curcumin and the carotenes.
Whereas in the US, all
our colors are artificial.
Blue No. 1 is used in
both the US and the UK,
but we also have Blue No. 2, Red 40,
Yellow 5, and Yellow 6.
Blue 2 is a less common one.
It's also known as indigo carmine.
Now, the good news is it won't
make your kids hyperactive.
The more interesting news is that Blue 2
is filtered rapidly through the kidneys,
and consuming enough of it
will turn your pee blue.
The practical use of this is so doctors
can highlight your urinary
tract for surgeries.
A less practical effect or use
is to freak out your friends.
Hey-o, we're doing jokes
in the script, apparently.
Hey, welcome to "Food Wars"!
So anyway, turns your piss blue.
Speaking of carmine,
what about the carmine
used in British M&M's?
Standard carmine is a red food coloring
with the code names Red 4 or E120.
It's a natural food dye,
but what is the natural source, you ask?
It's cochineal beetles.
If you grind up cochineal beetles,
you're left with a red powder,
which when mixed with
water and some chemicals
can be turned into a very stable dye.
Obviously, we're going to now
have to try and make our own.
But you can see the red color
coming off of it already.
Now I'm going to try and
put some of this in there,
mix it with some water,
and see what happens.
That has really worked. Wow.
Look how red that is! That's incredible.
As you can see, just by
chopping up some beetles
and mixing it with water,
we've got this incredible
kind of blood-red food dye.
Now, while apparently
synthetic alternatives
to carmine do exist, M&M's confirmed to us
that the carmine they use does
in fact come from beetles.
So, technically, every time
you eat a red M&M in the UK,
you're eating bugs.
So, do you want your kids hyperactive,
or do you want them eating beetles?
Not much of a choice, is it?
Here are all the M&M's
products you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
These are the M&M products
you'll find in the US
that you will not find in the UK.
I'm so excited for this,
Yuelei. You have no idea.
Oh, my God, I'm want to try
every single one of these.
And I'm going to right now.
All right, first up, peanut butter M&M's.
Love peanut butter M&M's.
Fudge brownie.
They're like the size of peanut M&M's,
but it's all chocolate inside.
I'm having a hard time
deciding the difference
between the fudge brownie
and regular chocolate.
Pretzel M&M's are my favorite M&M's.
These might be the best ones.
Every time M&M comes out with a new core,
it's always like, oh, who cares?
Pretzels, peanut butter, crispy.
And they're always amazing!
Mm.
Caramel M&M's.
A more manageable Rolo. These are great.
Almond. He's a new guy.
These are really good.
Dark chocolate M&M's.
Not a big dark chocolate guy.
A little more bitter
than the regular ones,
but they're still coated in candy.
Coffee nut. Oh, they're big.
Oh, and they're kind of, like,
the many shades of coffee-colored.
Oh, I don't know about these.
The only good coffee-flavored
thing is coffee.
Everything else is like, don't bother.
First miss.
Mint dark chocolate.
Smells a little bit like toothpaste.
Ooh. It's like, yeah, it's
got a nice refreshing ...
this could replace brushing
your teeth in the morning.
Eat a couple of these.
White chocolate peanuts.
Yeah, dude, yeah.
Like the peanut ones but
a little bit sweeter.
And, surprised this one is not in the UK.
It is English toffee peanut.
No.
One variety, mega peanut,
is also available here in
the US and not in the UK,
but at the time of filming this,
I was not able to get my hands on it.
From what I understand,
it's like the peanut's really big.
Now, we don't have any major
exclusive flavors in the UK,
but we do have some
linguistic differences.
For example, while the US has caramel,
we have salted caramel.
And while the US has fudge brownie,
we have chocolate brownie.
I want to see if you can
actually taste the salt
in the salted caramel.
You actually can.
Now, I am a sucker for salted caramel,
but these are really good.
We also have a bunch of
seasonal M&M's in the US.
These include Christmas options,
such as sugar cookie M&M.
What is up?
Oh, yeah.
Those are good.
Mint Christmas.
Do M&M's go bad? Christmas
was, like, two months ago.
Yeah. Ooh, yeah.
Bro. White chocolate pretzel snowballs.
I think we had these for the
Christmas episode. I forget.
White chocolate.
The pretzel gives it
that little bit of salt.
These are really good.
We also have Valentine's Day options.
This is a Cupid mix,
and it looks like the only difference
is that the M has a heart over it,
like there's a different printing on it.
I mean, it's fun to have themed candy,
but it's not a fun flavor.
I may have spoke too soon,
'cause we also have the Valentine's Day
Black Forest cake mix.
No, ugh.
There's also a dark chocolate Cupid mix
we could not get at time of filming.
Then we have some products
which aren't classic M&M's
but use the M&M's branding.
The main event here is probably this.
This is an M&M's chocolate
ball-pool party cake.
It says it serves 26.
I'm really struggling to see
how you'd even cut that into 26 pieces,
let alone have slices which
would then satisfy people.
He's smiling, but he
looks like he's kind of
smiling through the pain at the moment.
I feel you, buddy.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
Oh, God.
[laughs]
There we go.
Can you eat him, or is he plastic?
Let's find out.
I would assume edible.
He's edible. I'm not
sure what he's made of.
He does not taste good.
OK, I'm cutting myself a little piece.
It's actually really not terrible.
If I were 8 years old again
and someone gave me a piece
of this at a birthday party,
I wouldn't complain.
Following on from the cake,
we've got a few more exclusive
M&M's products in the UK,
starting with these chocolate bars.
You guys can get these in the US as well.
I think we share the peanut
and the milk chocolate options,
but we have crispy as an exclusive
and cookie as an exclusive.
They're basically just milk chocolate bars
with little pieces of crispy
M&M's or cookies inside.
Correct, we do have the chocolate bars
here in the US as well.
But one exclusive we have is this,
the almond M&M's chocolate bar.
Next up we have this M&M's
spread with crispy pieces.
Now, it's a chocolate- and
hazelnut-flavored spread
with crispy M&M's inside.
So it's basically like a
Nutella and M&M hybrid.
Well, yeah, I'm actually
pretty impressed by this.
It tastes basically the same as Nutella.
I don't know if they're actual M&M's
or just kind of the crispy
rice pieces inside this,
but either way, adds a nice little crunch,
you know, a bit of texture.
Next up, we have these M&M's
double chocolate cookies.
Now, the double chocolate in the name
comes from the fact that
they are chocolate cookies
and then they also
contain chocolate M&M's.
You know, as far as a crunchy
UK cookie goes, not too bad.
Next up, we've got two Easter egg options.
It's a sort of hollow chocolate egg,
usually comes with a
couple of bags of sweets
of your choosing, in this case, M&M's.
They're given to kids around Easter time
to celebrate the holiday.
Now, for M&M's, these are available
as either brownie or crispy options.
I actually don't know if
Americans do Easter eggs.
Joe, is that a thing in the States?
Easter eggs, Easter
candy, Easter chocolate,
Easter baskets, Easter bunny,
all that stuff is very
popular in America as well.
We can also get a bunch of nonstandard
M&M's stuff here in the US.
For instance, we have M&M
cookie ice cream sandwiches.
Weird, these boxes are
open. That's so weird.
It says four, but
there's only two in here.
I don't know what happened.
You can get them in
mint, classic chocolate,
and vanilla.
There's also a chocolate one
with ice cream that's also chocolate.
That is not available in my area.
See that? And then they got
the ice cream right there.
We also have something called
the Valentine's Day M&M popcorn bucket.
One, two, three packets of popcorn,
two boxes,
one of the milk chocolate
and one of the peanut.
Also something that I got similar to this,
and I think it's an exclusive,
it is milk chocolate
popcorn-flavored M&M's.
It's weird. Tastes like
popcorn and chocolate.
Now, in preparation for this episode,
I did something which no true Londoner
should ever have to do,
which is visit M&M's
World in Leicester Square.
Now, according to signs in the shop,
it's the largest candy shop in Europe
and also has the world's
largest candy wall.
I'm gonna be honest, I
absolutely hate M&M's World
and pretty much everything it stands for.
It's kind of like walking
into the museum of capitalism.
It's somehow an even bigger tourist trap
than, like, Buckingham Palace.
I just don't understand why
people would come to London
and make a beeline for the M&M's store.
So, I've not been to the
M&M's store in London,
but I've definitely been to the one
in New York City, in Times Square.
And I mean this as sincerely as possible,
it's awesome.
I'd never been in before,
and I wasn't really sure what to expect.
And I was disappointed, honestly.
I was expecting at least
some kind of innovative M&M flavors,
but it was just the same flavors
that you can normally buy in the store.
It's just kind of different
colors and different packaging.
The bulk of what they
had on offer in the store
is actually M&M's merch,
like the grotesque shirt
that I'm wearing now,
ironically, for the record.
I'm just so confused as to who would spend
their own money on this sort of stuff.
Like, why are you loving M&M's so much
that you're going to pay a brand
to let you advertise for them?
Harry, you are.
You know what isn't ironic?
How much they made on that shirt sale.
This is what we do. We like things.
We wear it to show people,
look at the thing I like.
It's a capitalistic world
and I'm a cog in the machine, fine.
I can't escape, so I might
as well be comfortable.
And that is my input on the matrix.
Don't unplug me, I'm happy!
All that said, I did find
one or two M&M's products
which I couldn't find anywhere else.
Firstly, there was one
of the M&M chocolate bars
with a flavor I couldn't
see anywhere else,
and that's hazelnut.
Then there were these
two sachets of powder.
Firstly, there is a cookie mix.
Apparently you add some
butter and some water to this,
and then you have some
ready-to-bake M&M cookies.
And then, finally, we have an
M&M's hot chocolate powder.
You know what this means:
We have to summon the mug.
It's the return of Buchi
and Wumi. Cheers, guys.
Oh, it's got M&M's in it. Whoa.
No, that's fine. It's
better than the Oreo one.
The bar was admittedly really low,
but given the option, I would, of course,
make this with milk instead of hot water,
and I think if you did that,
it would actually be pretty good.
Carrying on from the earlier discussion
about the M&M's stores,
I do just want to quickly call out M&M's
for having some really
questionable branding.
A big recurring theme is that the M&M's
are really sexualized in all
of the marketing materials.
There was that TV ad where the M&M
was kind of in bed with that guy's wife.
I feel like the green M&M
gets sexualized quite a lot.
And also, if you go on the
official M&M's website,
they have some really questionable bios.
For example, if you go on
the bio of the brown M&M,
you'll see that she has a
turn-on listed, which is power.
Her appearance is described
as "sexy, sophisticated,"
and her best attribute is
her "big, beautiful brain."
As part of my M&M's World
visit, I did a scan,
which told me which M&M
I was, and I got yellow.
So let's take a look at his bio.
So, apparently my likes are
pretty ladies and fluffy things.
My appearance is plump,
yellow, and all smiles,
which, yeah, kind of accurate.
Although the bad news
is I might be an incel,
because my shortcomings are
that nice guys finish last.
The idea of giving
these guys personalities
to begin with is like, Jesus Christ,
can't I just eat my candy in peace?
[rewinding]
In an unbelievable turn of events,
the very day after we
filmed most of this episode,
M&M's announced that they
would be rebranding their M&M's
to be more representative of the consumer.
They've backtracked on a lot
of the sexualization of the M&M's.
For example, the green M&M has swapped out
her high heels for sneakers,
and the brown M&M has had the turn-ons
removed from her bio on the website.
This whole thing prompted
an explosion of memes on the internet.
Someone went to journalism school
to write some of these headlines,
and I respect them for it.
I don't know why anyone ...
if you had an opinion on
this, for or against it,
you have entirely too
much time on your hands.
It's also worth pointing
out that someone suggested
the M&M's rebrand could
be suspiciously timed
and that they might be
trying to draw attention
away from an ongoing class action lawsuit.
Mars, the owner of M&M's,
along with several other
major chocolate producers
including Hershey's, Nestlé, and more,
have been accused of using cocoa
from plantations which
use child slave laborers.
Oh, God.
Mars told Bloomberg, "We do not comment
on any possible pending litigation."
Oh, that's ...
the fact that it wasn't a blanket,
"Of course not, what?"
The fact that they're like,
"Oh, we can't comment on it,"
it's like, that's a yes.
The lawsuit is still ongoing,
so we'll have to wait and see
if any more details emerge.
Was the timing of the rebrand
coincidental or cynical?
We'll let you guys decide.
I like how I just found out about that
after I ate all these M&M's.
Well, if it will make
everyone feel better,
I have a huge headache from
eating all this junk food.
In the US, the recommended
serving size of M&M's
is 28 grams, which is roughly 1 ounce.
So when it comes to classic M&M's,
the US version has more calories,
saturated fat, carbs, and sodium.
The UK M&M's actually
contain more total fat
as well as more sugar.
Sugar is the worst nutritional offender
as far as M&M are concerned.
28 grams of UK M&M's
contains just over a third
of your daily sugar allowance.
What about the least
healthiest M&M in the US?
Well, for us, there's a two-way tie
between the peanut butter and
the white chocolate peanut.
Both of these contain
150 calories per 28 grams
as well as 8 grams of fat.
In the UK, our least
healthy M&M is peanut.
A 28-gram serving of UK peanut M&M's
will contain 144 calories
as well as a slightly increased
7.28 grams of total fat.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pepsi in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Pepsi comes in
a range of portion sizes,
but these do vary slightly
depending on which type
of Pepsi you're buying.
We used to be able to get mini cans,
but they've been discontinued,
so now you can get classic
Pepsi in four portion sizes.
As a 330-milliliter can,
as a 500-milliliter bottle,
as a 1.5-liter bottle,
and as a 2-liter bottle.
In the US, our Pepsi comes
in these following sizes:
The mini can is the
smallest. 7.5 fluid ounces.
Next one up, the classic
can, 12 fluid ounces.
Then we move up to plastic bottles.
This one is 16.9 fluid ounces.
Then we got the 20-fluid-ounce bottle.
And if that's not enough,
we go up to 1-liter bottle. Liter of cola.
Then moving up a little bit
more, 1.25-liter bottle.
And then our biggest bottle
is the 2-liter bottle.
We can also get glass bottles,
but like the classic
can, they are 12 ounces.
Where regular Pepsi is concerned,
both countries cap out
at a 2-liter bottle.
However, in the UK, we
can go one step further
when it comes to diet and Max Pepsi.
Certain retailers, such as
Iceland or B&M, stock these.
A 3-liter bottle of
Pepsi Max or Pepsi diet.
We finally have something
bigger than America! We did it!
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing,
probably bad for the nation's health,
but, you know, nice to
be different for once.
There are some other
slight size differences
for the sugar and sugar-free
options in the UK as well.
For example, in the UK,
we can get a 1.25-liter bottle
of Pepsi Max or Pepsi diet,
which we can't get for the classic Pepsi.
The size differences are largely
down to the UK's sugar tax.
It's a tax which raised
the price of drinks
with more than 5 grams of
sugar per 100 milliliters.
The higher prices reduce the demand
for the full-sugar
versions of soft drinks,
making it less viable to sell
them in large containers,
such as the 3-liter.
But don't worry, because you
can still get sugary Pepsi
in bulk quantities.
Our largest bulk is the
36-can pack of Pepsi,
and that's the 12-ounce cans.
That is 432 fluid ounces of soda,
or 3.375 gallons, of Pepsi.
Now, that pack of cans is at
least available at Sam's Club,
possibly Costco, I don't know,
but I went to Sam's Club,
and unfortunately they
would not let me buy it
without a membership.
So, the best I could do are these pictures
of me with the packs.
That is much larger
than our largest option,
which is this, a 24-pack of cans.
Not only is our multipack
only two-thirds the size
of the American one,
but the cans themselves are also smaller.
A can in the UK contains 330 milliliters,
while a can in the US contains 355.
This means that the total for our 24-pack
comes to 2.09 gallons.
Even if we had a 36-pack,
it would still be smaller
than the American version.
We need three extra cans
to make up the difference.
Here are all the Pepsi
products you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Pepsi
products from the US
you won't find in the UK.
We'll start with the
exclusive flavors of Pepsi.
In the UK, we have Pepsi Max raspberry.
It's got that really comforting,
extremely nostalgic artificial
blue-raspberry flavor
that you're used to.
On Pepsi's UK website, it
also said they do lime Pepsi,
but I wasn't able to find that
at any of the stores I tried.
Whoops.
We have a few exclusive
Pepsi options of our own.
Starting down here, we
have Pepsi real sugar,
which is in fact made with real sugar,
not the high-fructose-corn-syrup stuff.
Not bad.
We also have Pepsi mango
and Pepsi mango zero sugar.
Seems like a weird fruit choice.
Whoa, smells good.
I'm surprised by how good this is.
And they got the mango zero sugar.
Ooh, already smells drastically different.
It's got a real chemically aftertaste.
Not as good as the regular.
This one here is
Pepsi soda shop cream soda.
Mm.
Very nice.
And the last one, Pepsi vanilla.
I'm gonna be honest with you, Pepsi,
could use a lot more vanilla.
It's, like, vanilla-kissed.
[burps] There it is.
All right, right now what I want to do
is compare the already-tasted
real sugar Pepsi
to the regular Pepsi, which
has high-fructose corn syrup.
Regular Pepsi.
[coughs]
Pepsi's harsher than Coke.
Yeah.
About to say something
somewhat controversial,
but bring it, I want all the smoke.
Real sugar Pepsi tastes just like Coke.
It's just smoother.
This is like ... [burps]
Yeah, this is, like, harsher.
Joe was kind enough to
send me some American Pepsi
as well as some real sugar Pepsi,
so I'm going to do a three-way taste test
and see if I can tell the difference.
Pepsi No. 1.
That's very, like, strong flavor,
quite a syrupy texture to it almost.
Pepsi No. 2.
Yeah, very sweet, but almost
in a more gentle kind of way.
And then No. 3.
More similar in kind of, like,
I'd say sweetness and
mouthfeel to the middle one.
This one is the one that stood
out with the strongest taste,
in my opinion.
These two were very similar,
which is making me think
that these are the British
and real sugar Pepsis.
I'm not sure in which order,
but they had a more gentle taste,
whereas this one seemed
harsher and tasted very syrupy.
So I'm going to guess British,
American real sugar,
American normal Pepsi.
I'm shocked.
These two tasted really similar to me,
and this one stood out, like I said,
and it wasn't particularly pleasant.
Maybe the UK needs to take
a leaf out of America's book
and just put high-fructose
corn syrup in everything.
The other exclusive Pepsi item in the UK
is this Pepsi SodaStream syrup.
For the uninitiated, a
SodaStream is a device
which lets you carbonate
your own drinks at home.
Now, as a sparkling-water obsessive,
I actually own one of these.
So we're going to make our own Pepsi.
So, what you do
is you get one of your
little SodaStream bottles,
fill it to the first line,
and attach it to the machine.
Then you press this button,
and the magic happens.
According to this bottle,
you add about half a cap
of the syrup to this.
That's quite cool.
The first thing I get is just Pepsi.
It tastes a lot like Pepsi Max.
There is a slightly unpleasant aftertaste,
which, I'm not sure
where that's come from.
Maybe I used too much syrup. Who knows.
But I think, yeah, in terms of recreating
a fizzy drink at home with
not a lot of equipment,
it's pretty good.
And that's pretty much it
as far as Pepsi exclusives are concerned,
but we're not stopping there.
PepsiCo owns more beverage brands,
but it does differ depending
on which country you live in.
Now, while in the US,
Keurig Dr Pepper owns 7Up,
in the UK, it's actually owned by PepsiCo,
which means that technically
all of these are Pepsi exclusives.
British 7Up comes in four forms.
As classic 7Up, a 7Up
Free, 7Up cherry Free,
and as a SodaStream syrup.
That's actually not bad.
It doesn't have the unpleasant aftertaste
that the Pepsi one did.
That to me just tastes like 7Up.
One other thing that's worth pointing out
is that in the UK, this
is considered lemonade.
Like, if you walk into
a pub or a restaurant
and ask for a glass of lemonade,
this is what you'll get.
Like, a clear sparkling beverage.
Is that not the case in America?
That is definitely not lemonade,
and it is super weird.
Lemonade is lemon, not juice, right?
But you squeeze lemons
in water and mix it up,
and it's, like, more
refreshing and kind of tart.
And it's closer to a lemon juice.
It's definitely not carbonated.
In front of me we have
something that's brand new,
and it is called Pepsi Nitro.
What is it? Wait, excuse me.
Nitro Pepsi, flip 'em.
Looks to be a tall boy of Pepsi
that, according to the can,
is nitrogen-infused cola
with smaller bubbles and a smoother taste.
[drink fizzes]
Did you hear that? Oh, man!
That's a pretty hard pour, right?
It's not going crazy like a
normal Pepsi would, right?
I'm more excited about the vanilla.
Let's really get really good
audio on this one now. Ready?
[drink fizzes]
Hard pour.
Yeah, it's a little bit smoother.
It still tastes just like Pepsi.
Not as carbonated, which is fine.
Do the vanilla.
Much better. Ooh, that's nice. Yeah.
The issue I'm having with it
is that the only time
soda is that "smooth"
is when it's flat.
I'll f--- with it, but it's just OK.
Pepsi has a few exclusive
brands in the US,
including Mug Root Beer,
Sierra Mist, and Bubly.
They're a carbonated-water brand.
Mug Root Beer.
I was the master at being able
to tell different root beers on taste.
I could tell them apart.
That information is, like, in my DNA.
One of these days we'll
do a root-beer lineup,
a root-beer taste test.
I guarantee I will ace that test.
Yeah, it's taking me back.
Also, they got Sierra Mist.
I hate Sierra Mist.
It's a lemon-lime flavor.
I don't know if they're
competing with Sprite or 7Up.
Always hated this.
Sprite is better. 7Up is better.
Sierra Mist tastes the way
fruit-flavored shampoo
smells, if that makes sense.
[burps] OK.
This'll be my ranking
system, from best to worst.
So, first we're going to go strawberry.
No, I do not like that.
Cherry.
I think these all might be bad.
That one's a little better
than the strawberry one.
Pineapple.
Nope, woof!
Grapefruit, ugh.
Low expectations on this one.
Oh, my God, that smells like an armpit.
Oh, man, if I went into a public restroom
and it smelled like this, I would run out.
No!
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
Yeah, that's the worst one.
Lime. Can't screw up lime, come on.
Congrats, lime, you're
the least offensive.
Peach.
What the hell happened?
Why are these all so bad?
Raspberry.
Oh, man, the smell of that.
It says natural flavor.
It does not taste natural at all.
At all. At all.
Ah, blackberry.
OK, that's the best one,
but it's not very good.
And last and not -- mango.
OK, so we had the mango,
so they know how to flavor
things mango properly.
The mango Pepsi's fantastic.
I mean, yeah, these two are the best one.
They're not very good.
Bubly is not very good.
How could they screw these up this bad?
PepsiCo also owns Mountain
Dew in the UK and the US,
but that is a story for another episode.
Story time. Anyone ever
remember or heard of New Coke?
Well, you can thank Pepsi for that.
Once upon a time,
Coca-Cola was actually
losing market share,
and Pepsi put out a
very popular ad campaign
where people were blind
taste-testing Coke and Pepsi
and picking Pepsi.
So Coke panicked,
and they pushed to market
a beverage called New Coke,
which is basically Coke
that was supposed to
taste more like Pepsi.
Guess what? Huge marketing blunder.
Not only did Coca-Cola fans get annoyed
that they changed the formula
of a beverage they liked,
but all New Coke was doing was
giving Pepsi more attention.
Either way, just 79 days
after introducing New Coke,
Coke announced that
they'd be bringing back
the original drink,
called Coca-Cola Classic.
And you will maybe notice,
for, like, 20 years,
Coca-Cola was called Coca-Cola Classic.
It had "Classic" on there.
Have you ever wondered why?
That's because they wanted
to make it perfectly clear,
this is not that New Coke that you hated
from 1988 or whatever.
So, Pepsi, they had their day in the sun,
but to be honest, I mean,
Coke is clearly the more dominant brand.
Speaking of product failures,
remember Crystal Pepsi?
That was widely considered
to be one of the biggest
product failures ever.
Time magazine put Crystal Pepsi at No. 3
on the biggest-fails list.
Thrillist called it "Soda
World's Greatest Fail."
But why?
Soda sales were stagnant
in the early '90s,
with consumers instead opting
for clear and caffeine-free sodas.
Former Pepsi marketing exec David Novak
pitched a drink that was both,
and Crystal Pepsi was born.
The recipe was developed by
food scientist Surinder Kumar,
and Pepsi ended up with a clear drink
that maintained an almost
identical taste to Classic Pepsi.
They rushed it out in time
for the 1993 Super Bowl.
It was backed by a $40
million ad campaign,
and they did sell about half a
billion dollars' worth of it.
But by March of '93,
the hype quickly faded.
Consumers did not love the new flavor,
and the concept was even parodied by "SNL"
in a "crystal gravy" sketch.
Hilarious.
Roughly one year after launch,
Crystal Pepsi was discontinued.
But if you never got the chance to try it,
there's still hope for you.
Pepsi's bringing Crystal
Pepsi back for a limited time
to celebrate its 30th anniversary.
You can't buy it in stores,
but you can enter a contest
by sending them a picture of yourself
from the '90s on Twitter.
Here is my entry.
I've got a story of my own.
Remember that time when
Pepsi briefly became
the world's sixth-most-powerful
military force?
It all started in 1959
at the American National
Exhibition in Moscow.
When a discussion between
the then vice president, Richard Nixon,
and Nikita Khrushchev became heated,
a Pepsi exec called
Donald Kendall stepped in
to hand Khrushchev a glass
of Pepsi to cool him down.
Khrushchev enjoyed Pepsi so
much that arrangements were made
for it to be imported
from the US to Russia.
As part of the deal, Pepsi
even negotiated a monopoly,
locking Coca-Cola out of the country.
The drink's popularity exploded
in an otherwise uncontested market.
But there was one problem: payment.
The Russian ruble wasn't accepted
outside of the Soviet Union,
so the Russians had to come up
with an alternative arrangement.
They settled on a
universal currency: vodka.
Russia traded thousands of
cases of Stolichnaya vodka
for Pepsi syrup throughout
the '60s and the '70s.
However, they did run
into problems in the '80s.
Pepsi's popularity in Russia
combined with a boycott
due to the Soviet-Afghan War
meant that vodka just wasn't
going to cut it anymore.
Here's where things get fun.
In the spring of 1989,
Pepsi and the Soviet Union agreed a deal
whereby Pepsi would be
given 17 old submarines
and three warships.
They would then sell them for
scrap to pay for the Pepsi.
Therefore, for a short period of time,
Pepsi controlled the
sixth-most-powerful navy in the world.
Now that is a food war.
Here's everything in a Pepsi in the US.
Carbonated water,
high-fructose corn syrup,
caramel color, sugar,
phosphoric acid, caffeine,
citric acid, natural flavors.
Here is everything in Pepsi in the UK.
Carbonated water, sugar,
color (caramel E150d), phosphoric acid,
and flavorings including caffeine.
Now, obviously Pepsi
won't go into specifics
on the flavorings used,
because the recipe is a
closely guarded secret.
Or is it?
Pepsi was invented in
North Carolina in 1893
by a man named Caleb Bradham.
First it was called Brad's Drink,
but then they renamed it Pepsi in 1898.
It comes from the fact
that it was marketed
as relieving dyspepsia,
another word for indigestion.
It's giving me indigestion,
so that's weird.
However, in 1923, the
original Pepsi-Cola company
went bankrupt due to
fluctuating sugar prices
after World War I.
As part of the bankruptcy filing,
Bradham had to release
the recipe for Pepsi,
as it was a company asset,
and it's still publicly
available to this day.
So you can make your own Pepsi at home
simply by combining sugar,
water, caramel color,
lime juice, phosphoric
acid, alcohol, lemon juice,
orange juice, cinnamon oil,
nutmeg, coriander (cilantro),
and petitgrain, which is an essential oil
extracted from the leaves and
twigs of bitter orange trees.
Yeah, just those things.
The rights to Pepsi were eventually bought
by a man named Charles Guth,
who was then the president
of the Loft Corporation,
which later merged into PepsiCo.
They of course claim
that they reformulated the
recipe after the takeover,
but the original is still
there for all to see.
Enough with the history lesson.
What is the difference
between US and UK Pepsi?
That is why we are here.
First, let's talk about acids.
Both the UK and the US acidify their Pepsi
with phosphoric acid.
It's a weak acid which is
primarily used as a fertilizer.
When added to foods, it
provides a tangy taste,
but it's also been linked
to causing kidney stones
as well as osteoporosis.
The US also uses citric acid in its Pepsi.
Citric acid is a more common
and generally safer acidifier in foods,
but it's one of the things in sodas
that will cause tooth enamel to erode
after repeated consumption.
I happen to have some of that right here.
Whoo!
That's sour.
Another major difference in Pepsi
is that in the US, we sweeten our Pepsi
with high-fructose corn
syrup in addition to sugar.
High-fructose corn syrup is everywhere
in American sodas and candies.
Government subsidies make it super-cheap
for American farmers to grow corn,
and food manufacturers use
corn syrup to save money
instead of importing sugarcane
from places like Mexico and Brazil.
Corn syrup is hard to
find at all in the UK.
We did manage to track
down this small bottle,
but only in a specialist grocery store.
Even then, it's just regular corn syrup
and not high-fructose.
The good news is, is
that it isn't actually
any worse for you than sugar.
The main impact is on the taste,
which explains why we have a
Pepsi made with real sugar.
Here it is, a version of the US drink
which does not contain any corn syrup.
This version actually has
the exact same ingredients
as the UK Pepsi.
Anything else to note?
Well, our old friend
caramel color is back.
In the UK, it's listed as caramel E150d,
while the US just lists caramel color.
This is a somewhat
controversial food coloring
used to give things like Pepsi
a distinctive golden-brown tinge.
There are four classes of caramel color,
classes I through IV.
Studies have suggested
that the production of classes III and IV
create a byproduct that
may put people at risk
of developing cancer.
Of course.
Why can't we enjoy anything?
While the FDA has stopped
short of banning caramel color,
the state of California added
it to its Proposition 65
list of chemicals known to cause cancer
and birth defects or reproductive harm.
Are these potentially harmful
caramel colors in our Pepsi?
Well, in the UK, the answer is yes.
We know that class IV caramel
color is used in the UK
because sulfite ammonia
caramel has the E number E150d,
which is on the list.
What about in the US, where it just says
caramel color without specifics?
We reached out to Pepsi
to ask which class they use over here.
And their answer was: nothing.
They said they would not comment
on the specific ingredients
due to proprietary issues.
Yeah, guys?
You're afraid that
detail's gonna really help,
uh,
cut into your competition?
So, your Pepsi may or may not
be putting you at risk of cancer.
So glad we cleared that up.
In the US, a can of Pepsi
contains the following.
150 calories,
0 grams of fat,
41 grams of carbohydrates,
and all those are sugars,
and 30 milligrams of sodium.
A can of Pepsi in the UK
contains the following.
135 calories,
0 grams of fat,
36 grams of carbs,
of which 36 grams are sugars,
and 4 milligrams of sodium.
Obviously the alarming
stat here is the sugar.
Just one can of US Pepsi
contains 80% of your
daily sugar allowance.
Really, one?
Ugh.
The UK statistic is slightly better,
at just 72% of your daily allowance,
but that is still a lot of sugar
in a relatively small amount of liquid.
There's also some caffeine in Pepsi.
A 12-ounce can contains
38 milligrams of caffeine,
which is about half as much
as an 8-ounce cup of coffee.
I of course am drinking
both Pepsi and coffee at the same time.
Pepsi doesn't openly disclose
its caffeine content in the UK,
but according to a website I found
called caffeineinformer.com,
a can of UK Pepsi Max contains
42 milligrams of caffeine.
The US equivalent of Pepsi
Max is Pepsi zero sugar,
but a can, not pictured here,
has over 69 milligrams of caffeine.
N-n-n-n-nice.
[air horn goes off]
Making it significantly more caffeinated
than the UK version.
But the good news: According to the FDA,
you need to consume 1,200
milligrams of caffeine
in a short period of time to
put your health in danger.
That's about 18 cans of Pepsi zero sugar.
I like a challenge, let's go.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all
the differences between
Mountain Dew in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Mountain Dew
comes in three portion sizes.
Firstly, we have this 330-milliliter can.
Then we have a 500-milliliter bottle.
Then we have our largest size,
which is a 1-liter bottle.
In the US, Mountain Dew
comes in six portion sizes.
The smallest is this 7.5-ounce mini can.
Then we have our standard 12-ounce can,
then a 16-ounce,
or 1-pint, can.
Then we go to bottles.
We have a 16.9, or 500-milliliter, bottle.
Jump up to the 20-ounce bottle,
and our largest size,
the 2-liter bottle.
As you can see, I don't
currently have a 1-liter bottle,
as it was surprisingly hard to track down.
I finally thought I'd found some on Amazon
and ordered a six-pack.
Then this showed up.
They helpfully sent me 12
500-milliliter bottles,
which is the same as six times 1 liter.
However, not really what we
were going for. Thanks, guys.
Ha! Our largest size is
double the size of the UK's,
and we don't even stop there.
In the US, our largest single
Mountain Dew item is this.
[cheering]
24-pack of 12-ounce cans.
That's 8.52 liters of Mountain Dew,
or 2.25 gallons.
It's a little unclear what
our largest single item is.
On the UK website, there
is a multipack listed,
but it doesn't say how
many cans are in one,
and I also couldn't find one anywhere.
So I called Britvic, who
manufacture Mountain Dew
here in the UK on behalf of PepsiCo,
and an employee for them told me that
the multipack actually doesn't exist.
The largest item that the company had
on their own records that
they produce is this.
A 24-pack of cans.
However, this is technically
marketed at retailers
rather than consumers, as you can see
by the fact that they
have prices on the cans.
We don't usually count
wholesale on this show,
so technically a 1-liter
bottle is our largest size,
if you can find one.
Joe: That makes the US's largest item
752% larger than the UK's.
It's also worth pointing
out the difference in price
between Mountain Dew in the two countries.
Sugary sodas in the UK
get hit with a sugar tax,
which raises their price
in an effort to stop
people from drinking them.
If you buy a 500-milliliter Mountain Dew
from a Sainsbury's in the UK, for example,
it will cost you 1 pound 25 pence,
which was around $1.69
at the time of recording this.
Nice.
The closest thing at that
price point in the US
is this 2-liter.
According to Target,
this is listed as $1.98.
You must be joking.
This isn't even $2?
Look at this.
That is alarmingly cheap.
For every milliliter in the UK bottle,
you're paying 0.338 cents.
Every milliliter of this 2-liter
costs 0.0995 cents.
That's 70% cheaper than the UK price.
Hang on.
Don't you feel like when you
go to a bodega or something,
this is, like, a dollar?
So not only is Mountain Dew super cheap,
but then when you get
it at a sandwich shop
or something, you're getting gouged!
Oof!
Here are all the Mountain
Dew products in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Mountain Dew products
you can find in the US you
will not find in the UK.
[groans]
Show this video to the paramedics.
We can actually only get
three Mountain Dew products in the UK,
one of which I couldn't even find today.
I guess you could sort of call
our standard Mountain Dew
in the UK an exclusive,
because here it's marketed
as Mountain Dew Citrus Blast,
while in the US, it's just Mountain Dew.
This also comes in a diet version,
which is the thing that
I couldn't find today.
The only other thing we
can get in the UK is this,
which is a SodaStream Mountain Dew syrup.
For those of you who don't know,
SodaStream is a device which lets you
carbonate your own drinks at home.
PepsiCo owns both Mountain
Dew and SodaStream,
so I guess it made sense for them to just
mash their products together.
Now, I love sparkling water,
so I actually own my own SodaStream,
and we can use it to make
our own Mountain Dew.
Take one of your little
SodaStream water bottles,
fill it with water, screw
it into the machine.
Once it's nice and secure,
press the magic button.
SodaStream, if you want to sponsor me,
you know where to find me.
And bang. You have fizzy water.
Ta-da.
Nice splash of the syrup.
That is a strange color on that.
I don't think that's what I
was expecting it to look like.
So, I think our homemade stuff actually
might look slightly more appealing.
You could kind of pass this
off as more of a fruity soda
rather than Mountain Dew from the bottle,
which is a bit more translucent,
just a bit more pallid and weak,
and not really sure what's going on there.
That's actually not bad.
It's quite a mild flavor.
It's not actually aggressively sweet.
Also not too bubbly. I
guess you have a bit more
control over the bubble
level with the SodaStream.
Despite the difference in the color,
they actually taste really similar.
That's actually a pretty
accurate recreation.
[exhales]
Jesus Christ.
That's one of the sweetest things
I've ever tasted in my entire life.
God.
It's like they've crammed more sugar
than there is space into that. Ugh.
I am guaranteeing, Yuelei,
I'm going to throw up
in the middle of this.
In the US, we have something
you can't get in the UK,
and it's Mountain Dew zero sugar.
Apparently even diet Mountain Dew
still has some sugar in it.
I'm not surprised at all.
Let's see what we got.
Regular.
Zero sugar.
Wow, that's, like, really close.
I don't mean to do the
Mountain Dew zero sugar commercial here,
but it tastes exactly
like regular Mountain Dew.
Mountain Dew Frost Bite.
I have no clue what this is.
Oh, that's terrible. I don't
even know what that is.
This is an Avella classic.
I'm not playing. I love
Mountain Dew Code Red.
It tastes like — what's
that drink that you give kids
when they want alcohol?
Shirley Temple?
Right? What is that?
That's just Sprite and
cherry grenadine, right?
That's exactly what this tastes like.
Oh, man.
It's back, baby. Mountain Dew Snap'd.
It's the gingerbread Mountain Dew.
I mean, it still even has
Christmas shit on it, so.
It smells just like gingerbread cookies.
It's good. It's really good.
Mountain Dew Voltage.
"Dew charged with raspberry,
citrus flavor, and ginseng."
It says "charged," guys.
Look at this. This is like Windex!
Oh, no.
Yeah, it has, like, a
melted-popsicle flavor.
It's a really strong flavor.
It's Mountain Dew Spark.
"Dew with a blast of
raspberry lemonade." OK.
I've already hit a wall.
Oh, God.
It's like if you tasked a child
to make Kool-Aid.
It's, I can't believe
how strong this stuff is.
Mountain Dew Major Melon.
Watermelon Mountain Dew.
Look what's on here. Look
at what they put on here.
Do you see this?
Like, look at the
nightmare that's on here.
Oh, it smells exactly
like a Jolly Rancher.
I like Jolly Ranchers, but in liquid form?
No. Oh, this is really bad.
It's the most artificial-tasting
thing we've had so far.
To save me from getting
too bored in this section,
Joe was kind enough to send me
some Mountain Dew from America
as well as some Mountain Dew Code Red.
Let's do a little side by side
of British and American Mountain Dews.
Getting a rare taste
of yellow 5 in the UK.
Chin, chin.
Whoa.
What was that?
You know in the film "Limitless"
when he takes that pill
and it just completely rewires his brain?
I think that's what yellow 5
now does to British people.
I've had, like, two sips of this,
and I feel like I could fight God.
Now that I've tried the American version,
the British version kind of
just tastes like sadness.
There's basically no flavor
to it other than sugar,
whereas at least I think with this,
you get obviously a lot of sugar,
but then there's a bit
more citrus as well.
This has even more illegal
food colorings in it.
We have red 40 and blue 1,
which, again, hard to come by in the UK.
OK, OK.
I think I actually might just prefer
classic American Mountain Dew.
This one felt like a religious experience,
whereas this one just felt OK.
So I'll stick to the classic Dew for now.
If that wasn't enough,
we also have a range of
Kickstart Mountain Dews.
These are cans of Dew mixed
with fruit juice and caffeine.
Imagine that. Caffeine.
Black cherry.
Now that it said juice in there,
I really taste the juice here.
Ooh, and electrolytes. It's like Gatorade.
Fruit punch. Love fruit punch.
Oh, no. That's very bad.
Full disclosure, pineapple orange mango,
I had to get a case of these
just to get the one for the video, so,
been working on these all week.
This one's pretty good.
Oh, man. Caffeine meter is just exploding.
Orange citrus.
Yeah, it's not bad.
Grape.
[burps]
That's the grapiest-tasting
grape thing, yeah.
The flavors aren't as harsh,
'cause they cut it with juice.
So, yeah, I kind of like the Kickstarts.
Is that everything? 'Cause I'm getting
a bit bored over here.
I might just go and make a cup of tea.
Sorry, Harry, we have even more options.
We have Mountain Dew Amp energy drink.
More caffeine, I'm assuming.
This is the original. You can
also get it in Cherry Blast.
[Windows shutdown sound]
Oh, man, that's really weird.
Whoa.
[inhales]
[exhales]
[kettle boiling]
Ha ha, if that wasn't enough,
we also have Mountain Dew Energy.
Why?
What was this?
Oh, Jesus.
They even broke — oh, my God, look,
they even broke it down on here.
Two cups of coffee.
5% juice, no added sugar, zinc.
Zinc?
What's zinc got to do with anything?
For all I know the can's made of zinc.
Oh, here it goes.
"Zinc helps support immune function."
I mean, I feel like I'm gonna drink this
and, like, try and run
through a brick wall.
What's that doing for my health?
"Citicoline and caffeine in combination
have been shown to help
improve attention."
Get —
get out of my face with this on here!
[groans]
[echoing] Show this
video to the paramedics.
[groans]
Let's do this. Orange Breeze.
Orange Breeze, right?
A nice breeze of orange?
Moments before you
tackle a stranger, bite into
their neck for sustenance?
Oh, that's really bad.
I don't think so.
They shouldn't even have it here.
They should just have like a Capri Sun,
like, two holes here,
and you just bite into
it, like "Teen Wolf,"
and drink it that way.
Is that possible to do that?
Pomegranate Blue Burst.
This is driving me out of my mind.
I've never had a pomegranate
that tastes like that,
and if I did, I would spit it out.
Oh, Strawberry Melon Spark.
Ugh.
No. Melon drinks are bad.
Peach Mango Dawn.
The dawn — a new dawn is here.
Oh, my vision is starting to blur.
Tropical Sunrise.
They've somehow bottled energy.
Ah!
Like licking a 9-volt!
The last exclusive Mountain Dew product
we're gonna cover
before I go totally blind
is Mountain Dew Game Fuel.
It's the first beverage, quote,
"designed just for gamers."
For real?
Hey, sitting for 12 hours at a time
doing literally nothing
staring at a flashing screen?
Drink this. Your muscles
won't atrophy as fast?
I'm not quite sure what's in here
to make it better for gaming,
but the flavors they have is Cherry Burst,
Berry Blast, original,
Tropical Strike, and Orange Storm.
Let's take out the flavors
and go through those words one more time.
Burst!
Blast.
Strike.
Storm.
Stupid.
You know, it's not as
strong as the energy drinks.
The Charged Berry Blast.
Charged Berry Blast.
Ooh.
Ah, man.
Feel like I'm pulling
the tab out of a grenade.
You know, I'm surprised.
These aren't as harsh
as the energy drinks.
I'm feeling myself getting
ready to game, Yuelei!
Getting ready to do some gaming!
Eh? I'm about to whoop
some Candy Crush ass!
This one is the Charged Tropical Strike.
This one's not that bad.
Full disclosure, I thought
these were going to
hands down be the worst.
I still don't like them, but.
Ooh! Charged Cherry Burst.
Bursting with cherry.
Here's the issue. Are they
going to make me a better gamer?
There's only one way to find out.
I'm going to play an extreme game.
That's right.
Let's do today's Wordle.
I'm going to take a sip and
then put in a five-letter word.
An extreme five-letter word.
Skate.
Board.
Mm.
Yuelei: How about blast?
There you go!
This Game Fuel's not helping.
Taste. Oh, wait, not E though.
OK, blank, A S T, blank.
Let's do casts.
OK. Maybe nasty?
N A S T Y?
All right, Wordle, here we go!
Is nasty it?
Oh-ho-ho!
That's right.
So what have we learned?
Uh, me?
Nothing.
Carry on, don't let me interrupt.
If that wasn't enough, Mountain Dew
recently partnered with
the Boston Beer Company
to create hard Mountain Dew,
a boozy spiked-seltzer
version of Mountain Dew.
And it comes in four flavors,
original Mountain Dew,
Baja Blast, oh, God,
black cherry, and watermelon.
And you're asking, "Joe, where is it?
I wanna see you get drunk!"
Well, I'm in California,
and it currently is only
available in the United States
in Tennessee, Iowa, and Florida.
Of course it's in Florida.
Joe, I think we're gonna need
the lab coats for this one.
Let's do it.
There's a fun FAQ on the
UK Mountain Dew website
explaining why the American
version of the product
isn't sold here, citing EU regulations.
There are some pretty major
differences between the two,
some of which are potentially harmful.
The US sweetens its Mountain Dew
with high-fructose corn
syrup instead of sugar.
Well, it's not necessarily
any worse for you.
It provides an even sweeter taste
with a slightly more chemical flavor.
The US also flavors its
Dew with orange juice,
which isn't specifically
listed in the UK ingredients.
One thing to look out for in
the US is sodium benzoate.
This is a sodium salt
which food producers
use as a preservative.
On its own, it's harmless,
but when it's mixed with certain acids,
like erythorbic or ascorbic acid,
it can form benzene.
Benzene is a known carcinogen
linked to causing cancer
in factory workers who've
been exposed to it.
The good news is US
Mountain Dew also contains
calcium disodium EDTA,
aka calcium disodium ...
Automated voice:
Ethylenediaminetetraacetate.
This can't be spelled right. Terraacetate?
Look, there's two A's next
to each other in that word!
With the exception of aardvark,
I've never seen two
A's next to each other.
And that's how that word starts!
This is a flavor enhancer,
but it actually helps
mitigate the formation of benzene.
Fantastic. They added
poison chemicals into it,
then they just added more chemicals
to stop it from being so poisonous.
Studies have shown that it
chelates the metallic ions
that catalyze hydroxyl radical formation.
It's a complicated way of saying that
it removes the fuel from the fire.
Mm.
Talk about teeth for a second,
because Mountain Dew is
pretty bad for your teeth.
When a man sued PepsiCo in 2009,
he alleged that he found a mouse
in his can of Mountain Dew.
But experts called in by PepsiCo said
that couldn't have been true
because Mountain Dew would
have dissolved the mouse
into a jellylike substance.
Oh, my God.
If it is strong enough to
dissolve an entire mouse,
you can imagine the
effect Mountain Dew has
on the enamel of your teeth.
But why is this happening?
It comes down to two things.
Sugar and acid.
Tooth enamel will start to erode
if your mouth's pH level drops below 5.5.
Mountain Dew has a pH of
around 3.3, which is acidic,
but actually on the
better end of the spectrum
as far as sodas are concerned.
Sugar itself has a neutral pH,
so why does it aid tooth decay?
Our mouths play host
to a range of bacteria.
They're usually harmless
and can even be helpful
by fighting things like gingivitis.
However, they also love sugar,
and when they eat it, they produce acid.
Bacteria like Streptococcus mutans
will metabolize sugar into lactic acid,
which will then erode your teeth.
The more sugar in a soda, the
more food these bacteria have
and the more acid they'll produce,
so sugar isn't causing it per se,
but it is aiding tooth decay.
Acids commonly used in soda
include citric acid and phosphoric acid.
Firstly, these acids will
lower the pH of your soda
and contribute to regular erosion.
But they're also examples
of polybasic acids.
These bind to the calcium in our teeth
and cause us to lose
enamel through dissolution.
It's kind of like how you can use acid
to dissolve rust on a metallic object.
All in all, while Mountain
Dew might not have
one of the lowest pHs when
compared to other sodas,
its sugar content combined
with its other ingredients
means that it is one of
the worst for your teeth.
A 2004 study place it as
the second-worst offender
for the dissolution of tooth enamel,
second only to Sprite.
Really? Sprite's worse? Hm.
And the bad news is the
sugar-free versions of sodas
don't seem to be any less harmful.
The replacement sweeteners
have the same effect
on the bacteria in your teeth.
If you're worried about your teeth,
it's better to drink a soda quickly
than it is to continuously sip it
and prolong the exposure.
Or, you know, you could
just stop drinking soda.
Interestingly, the UK version
actually has 1 more gram of sugar
when compared to the American version.
But our Mountain Dew is
slightly more calorific
and has double the
sodium of the UK version.
The bottles contain 132% and 130%
of your daily sugar
allowance, respectively.
Let's find out what that looks like.
Wait, this is for how big of a thing?
No, way. Yeah!
Oh, my God.
That's 50. We're not done yet.
That's an appalling amount of sugar.
I'm still gonna drink it.
Another thing worth pointing out
is the caffeine content
of your Mountain Dew.
In the UK, many supermarkets will actually
list Mountain Dew as Mountain Dew Energy.
This is because we have
stricter rules in the UK
about what does and doesn't
count as an energy drink.
In the UK, sugar is a major factor
in deciding whether or not
something is an energy drink,
as opposed to just caffeine.
Mountain Dew doesn't actually
disclose its caffeine content in the UK.
All I could find was this
Twitter reply from 2018
where they said it used
to be an energy drink,
but then they reformulated it
and now it has a similar
amount of caffeine to Pepsi.
They claim that this is less than half
the caffeine content of a cup of coffee.
Regular Mountain Dew contains
72 milligrams of caffeine
per 16 ounces.
There's around 92 milligrams of caffeine
in the same amount of Kickstart,
almost one and a half
espressos' worth of caffeine.
Moving up, Mountain Dew
Amp, original and cherry,
contain 142 and 160 milligrams of caffeine
per 16 ounces,
more than a double espresso.
The worst offender is Mountain Dew Energy.
One of these cans contains
180 milligrams of caffeine
per 16 ounces, which is
basically a triple espresso.
For reference, the FDA recommends that
the average healthy
adult shouldn't consume
more than 400 milligrams
of caffeine per day.
That's just over two of
those Mountain Dew energies.
It's around the 1,200-milligram mark
where you're actually
putting yourself in danger.
According to the FDA,
ingesting 1,200 milligrams of caffeine,
and you may experience seizures
or put yourself at risk
of cardiac arrhythmia.
So please do not drink more
than six of these at one time.
The "good" news is that
the lethal dose of caffeine
is around 5 grams,
so to actually overdose on Mountain Dew,
you'd need to chug 28 of
the Mountain Dew Energies
in pretty quick succession.
What a way to go.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Monster Energy
in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Officially speaking,
classic Monster Energy
only comes in one portion size in the UK,
a 500-milliliter can.
I looked around for other sizes online,
and I thought I'd found
some 440-milliliter cans,
but unfortunately the seller just sent me
a bunch more regular cans.
Only on "Food Wars" are we annoyed
when they send you more than you paid for.
Classic US Monster Energy
comes in two sizes:
the standard 16-ounce cans
or the mega Monster Energy
can, which is 24 ounces.
Good Lord.
That's 710 milliliters,
a 42% increase of the largest UK can.
This is too big.
This looks like the canister of ooze
that fell in the sewer and
made the Ninja Turtles.
When you buy other Monster
products in the UK, however,
some of them do come in different
sizes to the classic can.
For example, an Espresso
Monster can in the UK
is just 250 milliliters.
Certain Monster Ultra flavors come in a
553-milliliter mega can.
And if you get a bottle
of Monster HydroSport,
it comes in a 650-milliliter bottle.
The type of Monster Energy you drink
also affects the can size in the US.
Java Monster cans come in 15 fluid ounces,
and the Rehab Monsters come in cans
of 15.5 fluid ounces.
16's too much. 15.5? Print it!
What about the largest
multipack item by volume?
Well, in the UK, it's a
12-pack of Monster HydroSport,
which totals 9.75 liters of Monster.
That's quite a lot.
That pales in comparison to
the US's largest multipack.
That's 24-pack
of 16-ounce cans.
It's a total of 11.365 liters of Monster
and a 16.5% increase of the UK multipack.
I didn't get it, but it is at Target,
so here's a video of me holding it up.
I thought I was taking a picture.
That's me realizing that,
oops, it's on video.
Here are all the Monster
Energy products you'll find
in the UK, including those
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Monster
Energy products in the US,
including a bunch you
won't find in the UK.
Not only are we going to
talk through all these,
but we're also going to taste them
and provide some thoughts.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead!
Ugh. I mean, I barely survived
the Mountain Dew episode, so.
[laughs]
If you would've thought
by now on "Food Wars"
I would've learned my lesson,
you would think wrong.
Let's start with just the
classic Monster Energy drinks.
In the UK, we have two flavors
that you won't find in the US.
We could only get one of them
today, and it's this one:
The Lewis Hamilton 44 Monster Energy.
Lewis Hamilton is a Formula 1 driver.
He's one of the best ones of all time.
He's got, I think, seven
world championships,
and when he races, he wears
his lucky number, which is 44.
So they partnered with
Lewis to create this drink.
Let's give it a try.
It just smells like Red
Bull, I'll be honest.
It's probably a good time now to say that
I don't actually drink energy drinks.
I barely even drink coffee.
I'm very loyal to tea.
So this is gonna be fun.
Cheers.
It's just quite a standard
energy-drink flavor.
But yeah, goes down pretty smooth.
I wonder if this would make
me faster if I drank it.
The other exclusive UK Monster
Energy flavor is VR/46,
which unfortunately I wasn't
able to track down today.
The VR/46 can is designed
in collaboration with Valentino Rossi,
who's a very famous MotoGP driver.
I'm sad I couldn't get the can today,
because it gave me enormous
"Mario Sunshine" vibes.
Also, I need to stop drinking this,
because I've got a lot
more Monsters to try.
We have a few exclusive Monster
Energy drinks in the US.
Got the Monster Energy low-carb.
Oh, I hate how that smells.
Like, I instantly have a headache.
This has to be the first time in history
someone has poured Monster
Energy drink into a cup
and not drank it straight
from the can, right?
Who's ever done this before?
It tastes like electricity.
Next up, we have the
Monster Reserve watermelon
and the Reserve white pineapple.
Oh!
It tastes like sparkling juice, I guess.
There's this flavor of, like, static.
We got this one, this is the
Monster Import super premium.
What is the -- it's 18.6 fluid ounces.
But look at the top on this one.
Do you understand how to open this?
Oh, here we go.
This to me is like,
maybe don't drink this all in one sitting.
"While in Europe at the Spanish MotoGP,
we saw a cool resealable can
and knew it'd be perfect for Monster.
The can company said,
'only available in Europe.'
We said, 'BS, we gotta have it!'"
Whoa, Monster with the attitude!
"If you can open and close
the can with one hand,
you probably dated a lot
when you were younger."
I mean, everyone who's
drinking this is 12.
[grunts quietly]
How European.
The next category is Juiced Monster.
Well, in the UK, it's "Juiced,"
whereas in the US, it
seems to just be "Juice."
We do share most of our flavors
with the US in this category,
but we do have one or
two which are different.
We'll start over here, with Ripper.
When I first saw the can and the name,
I thought it was, like, based on Australia
because "you little ripper" is
a kind of Australian saying,
but then I read the can, and it turns out
it's actually based on
Hawaii and surf culture.
Sometimes you gotta just
throw a shrimp on the barbie
and say "you little ripper."
Ooh. This one smells nice.
I've sipped, like, two of these,
and I have a headache already,
so this is going well.
Then we have one which seems
to be a linguistic difference.
In the UK, you can find Juiced Monarch.
The can is adorned with
loads of butterflies,
and monarch is, of course,
a type of butterfly.
Whereas in the US, you guys have Papillon,
which is French for butterfly,
so I'm not really sure what
they've gone for there.
Obviously the UK has a monarch,
so maybe we've just gone
for the kind of royal theme
on this one. Who knows?
Ooh, I actually like that one.
Oh, no, this is bad.
I can't like these.
I'm not ready for an energy-drink era.
Our Juice Monster drinks
come in two exclusives.
The Juice Monster Papillon,
butterfly-themed, like UK Monarch.
I mean, I don't want
to keep drinking this,
but if I had to, I wouldn't be as upset.
Aussie lemonade style.
It's like, I'm surprised these
don't have alcohol in them,
because it smells like
an alcoholic beverage.
Oof.
Actually, I do like this.
It's not bad. Because it
tastes just like lemonade.
Like, I'm drinking it, it
doesn't feel like I'm also, like,
getting energized to fight.
Next up, we have some
coffee-and-Monster hybrid beverages.
In the UK on the website it
shows us Espresso Monster,
and these include
espresso and milk Monster,
vanilla Espresso Monster,
and salted caramel Espresso Monster.
However, if you click the buy-now link,
it takes you to a page
where it doesn't actually
seem to contain any Espresso Monster,
so I'm not sure if they've
been discontinued or not.
I was able to track down the
espresso and milk Monster
on the internet.
To be fair, that just
tastes like a coffee.
I don't get any kind of
Monstery elements from that,
which I think is a good thing.
The pace at which I talk is just going to
increase and increase
throughout this episode.
We have the coffee Monster in the US too.
However, over here we
call it the Java Monster,
and there's so many flavors.
Got the Java Monster
Mean Bean, the Loca Moca,
Kona blend, the Irish blend,
the low-cal vanilla light,
the salted caramel, the Swiss chocolate,
the cold brew latte, the
cold brew sweet black,
the farmer's oats vegan coffee,
and the 300 triple-shot mocha
and 300 triple-shot French vanilla.
I, of course, got the 300 triple-shot ...
mocha, aha.
"300 milligrams of natural caffeine."
Oh, go to hell.
"Robust coffee plus cream."
Oh, there's cream in this?
Says "SHAKE IT UP."
So I'm shaking it.
[can fizzing]
Why did it have me shake it up?
If you're at work and you see
any one of your fellow
employees walking in
in the morning drinking one of these,
like, it's time to find a new job,
'cause that guy is going to flip out.
Bad. Is there a napkin somewhere?
Next up, we've got Monster HydroSport.
Now, these are a range of
noncarbonated energy drinks
which are kind of targeted at athletes,
similarly to a Powerade-
or Gatorade-style beverage.
In the UK, they come in three flavors,
Charge, Striker, and Hang Time.
I've only got the Charge flavor today.
You can find the other
ones on the internet,
but we're going to give this one a try.
It's got a really strong,
slightly chemical smell to it.
But the taste actually isn't that bad.
In the UK, we drink a lot of squash,
which is kind of like a
concentrated-juice thing
that then you dilute with water.
It just tastes like a
kind of strong squash.
We're making a mess.
All right.
"Monster HydroSport. Energy
water for advanced hydration."
OK. They have a bunch of these.
This is the Tropical Thunder.
OK. Oof. Oof!
That looks exactly like Gatorade.
Ugh!
Oh, this is bad.
Blech.
Purple Passion.
Mm!
This one's, like, really bad.
But the second it touched my lips,
I was like, I've made a mistake.
Other hydro flavors include
super sport Killer Kiwi,
super sport Macho Mango,
super sport Red Dawn,
super sport Blue Streak,
Blue Ice, watermelon,
and hydro zero sugar, aka hydro white.
We have a couple of Monster product ranges
you won't find in the UK,
starting with the Rehab Monsters.
These claim to help you, quote,
"refresh, recover, and revive," end quote,
after a "heavy night."
Yeah. Right.
The two that I was able to get my hands on
are strawberry lemonade and tea lemonade.
The lemonades.
Yeah, no.
Yep. Looks exactly like the
first piss in the morning.
Maybe the worst one.
OK. So we have Rehab Monster watermelon.
You can also get a
Rehab Monster peach tea,
an orangeade, and a raspberry tea.
I was actually able to
track one of these down
on the UK Amazon website.
It seems to have been imported
from somewhere in Europe.
I think maybe Italy.
Quite bad.
I'm at that age now where
I'm always hungover.
What about you, Harry?
I'll be honest. If I'm hungover,
I'm going to go for a giant
full English breakfast,
loads of salt-and-vinegar crisps,
and then about 2 liters of fizzy water
instead of one of these.
Then our final exclusive
range is Muscle Monster.
These are exclusive shakes
with 27 grams of protein
and 157 milligrams of caffeine.
You can get them in
vanilla Muscle Monster energy drink shake
and chocolate Muscle Monster energy shake.
I don't have them.
It's probably a good thing.
Now, we can't get Muscle
Monster in the UK,
but I'm pretty sure I can just
combine a standard Monster
with some protein powder
and it'll have the same effect, right?
Of many bad ideas that
I've had on this show,
this might be the worst.
I'm going to go with 2
teaspoons of protein powder.
[laughs]
Charlie: That's the good stuff.
Harry: What on earth am
I doing with my life?
It's just currently kind
of formed a big layer.
There we go.
I hope you can see how
badly this has gone.
This is not mixed at all.
Ah, dear God.
Oh, God.
I think the texture's more
off-putting than the taste.
It's just like drinking a
really grainy Monster Energy.
The things we do for
gains! Am I right, guys?
Monster Energy products
have some ingredients
that you might want to watch out for.
But there are also lessons to be learned
about ingredients which sound scary
but are actually completely fine.
Here's the ingredients list
as it appears on a can of
classic Monster Energy drink.
I haven't even opened this yet.
Cheers, guys! I mean, it's
classic Monster Energy.
Oh, it's poison.
Here's the ingredients list
as it appears on a can of
classic Monster Energy in the UK.
Let's start with the good news.
If you take a look at the US list,
you might see some
scary-sounding chemicals,
like pyridoxine
hydrochloride or niacinamide,
which seemingly aren't
present in the UK drink.
However, these are
actually just full names
for vitamins B6 and B3, respectively.
Same goes for riboflavin and cyn --
cyanocobalamin in the US list,
which is just vitamin B2 and B12.
In fact, when you go through
the list and edit a couple
of other linguistic differences,
you'll see that the drinks
are actually identical
in the two countries.
That's not the only thing we can demystify
about Monster, either.
Oh, God. I'm, like, seething
from all this energy drink. Ah!
Yu may notice that
Monster contains taurine.
For years, taurine has been the subject of
some inaccurate rumors on social media.
Inaccurate rumors on social media? Huh?
Taurine has been associated with bulls,
drawing its name from the Latin "taurus."
Some people ran with
this and falsely claimed
that taurine is code for bull semen.
You have to be an absolute idiot
to think that taurine
is bull semen. Period.
The name taurine comes from the fact
that it was actually first
isolated from ox bile.
Even more good news is
that there's no ox spit
in Monster energy either,
as most food producers
will now use a synthetic
version of taurine
that isn't derived from animals.
This also means that Monster
is suitable for vegans.
OK. Enough defending Monster.
What about the more
questionable ingredients?
Some of the flavors of
Monster Energy drink
contain controversial food colors.
For instance, all these four
bad boys have red 40 in them.
This is the visual representation
of children bouncing off the walls.
All these got the red 40 in it.
Let's do a power
controversial-chemical taste test.
Bad.
Mm-mm.
Somehow worse.
I don't know what flowers taste like.
Definitely not that.
That's kind of nice, actually.
This other one that's sitting over here,
if you're wondering why it's over here --
sorry I'm talking, like,
superfast all of a sudden.
This s--- is really kicking in.
So, this section, the US portion of this,
is completely disorganized.
It's 100% my fault.
This, I just, what? I, what time is it?
These are food colorings
derived from petroleum.
They've received a lot
of attention in the past
due to concerns about their safety.
In 2007, a study from UK
academics linked red 40,
yellow 5, and yellow 6 to hyperactivity
in children, possibly adults,
and yellow No. 5 to also being
linked to causing cancer.
Gimme a dancing rat,
sometime now. Thank you.
While these dyes aren't illegal in the UK,
most manufacturers will
still avoid using them
because if they are added to food,
they must bear a warning label
which says that they "may
have an adverse effect
on activity and attention in children."
However, as Monster
Energy is kind of designed
to make you hyperactive,
it's one of the UK products
which still uses one of them.
Our Pipeline Punch and
Ultra Red Monster Energies
contain red 40, listed on
the ingredients as E129,
which means that they also have to have
the hyperactivity warning.
The good news for the UK
is that we stopped short
of using yellow 5 and
yellow 6 in our Monster,
instead opting to use carotenes
to color our yellow
drinks, like Mango Loco.
There was one other
Monster-based controversy
that came out of the British Isles.
The Republic of Ireland pulled
four varieties of Monster
from its shelves, including Juiced Ripper
and Lewis Hamilton 44, after
they were found to contain
excessive levels of propylene glycol.
Propylene gly-sol --
no idea if that's how it's pronounced --
is a chemical which has GRAS,
Generally Recognized as Safe,
status from the FDA.
It's mostly used in food as a humectant,
which is something which absorbs water
and provides additional nutritional value.
It has been the subject of
some hysteria in the past.
It's one of the main
ingredients of antifreeze,
as it can lower the
freezing points of liquids.
However, this level of it
would never be found in food or drink.
Even the Food Safety Authority of Ireland
said that the products it recalled
were unlikely to cause
any harmful effects.
Let's talk about caffeine for a second.
Regular Monster Energy in the UK contains
32 milligrams of caffeine
per 100 milliliters,
which equates to 160 milligrams
in a 500-milliliter can.
A regular can of Monster Energy in the US
also contains 160 milligrams of caffeine,
with a slightly higher
figure per milliliter
than the UK, as our cans
are slightly smaller.
That's roughly equivalent
to two shots of espresso,
which usually contain around 80 milligrams
of caffeine per shot.
If we're talking per milliliter,
the UK's most caffeinated Monster
would be the Espresso
Monster, which contains
around 60 milligrams of
caffeine per 100 milliliters,
almost double the amount
of the normal can.
However, the UK espresso cans
are only 250 milliliters.
That means that a whole can
of that contains less caffeine
than a whole can of the classic version.
The most caffeinated US Monster drink
is the Monster Java 300 line,
which, as the name suggests,
contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine per 15 fluid ounces.
Good God.
At what point does caffeine
intake become a problem?
The FDA says that 400
milligrams per day is generally
not associated with
dangerous negative effects.
But if you consume 1,200 milligrams
in a relatively short amount of time,
that's when the toxic effects
like seizures can start to be observed.
According to the FDA,
the life-threatening dose
of caffeine is 10 grams of caffeine.
It's surprisingly easy to get
ahold of pure caffeine online.
Without any age verification,
I was able to pay £23
for 100 grams of this,
which is theoretically
enough to kill 10 people.
We're going to weigh out
a 10-gram lethal dosage
just to show you how
little that actually is.
So that is roughly what's in there.
That right there is more
than enough caffeine
to kill a normal human being.
That was about 4 teaspoons' worth.
What's this like in terms
of Monster Energies?
Well, in the UK, you'd
need to drink 7.5 of them
to hit the 1,200-milligram mark,
but you'd need to drink 62.5 of them
to hit the 10-gram mark.
This means you'd be unlikely to die
just from the caffeine on its own,
but it's not unrealistic
that you may experience
some negative side effects
if you consume a lot of it.
It's a little more risky here in the US.
Just four of these Java 300 cans
can put you at risk of seizures,
although it'd probably take
33.3 of them to kill you.
Yeah. And you wouldn't die from caffeine.
You'd die from, like,
your bladder exploding
from having 33 of these.
How many fluid ounces is that?
What's 15 times 33?
It's worth mentioning that
in some stores across the UK,
they will ask for proof of age
in order to let you buy Monster Energy.
I got ID'd in a co-op trying
to buy some of the drinks
for this video. There's
no legal restriction
on the sale of energy drinks in the UK,
and they can technically
be sold to anyone,
but some retailers will
voluntarily cap them
to people over the age of 16.
This is a fantastic idea.
I'm not kidding. We should be doing that.
The age restriction is, no
one over 25 drinks this crap.
You stop drinking this when you get, like,
I don't know, responsibilities.
There's also a large amount
of sugar in Monster Energy.
In the UK, a 500-milliliter
can contains 55 grams of sugar.
That's 110% of your daily allowance.
A 16-ounce can in the US
contains 54 grams of sugar,
which is 108% your daily allowance.
Now remember, though, the US cans contains
around 30 milliliters
less than the UK can,
so proportionately speaking,
they're basically the same.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out
all of the differences
between Skittles in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Skittles come
in the following sizes.
Firstly, we have these
18-gram fun-size pouches.
Then we have these 45-gram bags.
Then we have a 125-gram bag of Skittles.
Next up is what I think
is the most common size,
a 152-gram bag.
Then we have this one, a
350-gram More to Share bag.
Then we have our largest
size, which is this one,
a 1-kilogram big-size share bag.
And in the US, our Skittles
come in these sizes.
First one, the fun size, 10 grams.
We got the 61.5-gram bag.
Next size, 99-gram box.
Yeah, the movie-theater pack.
The share size. 113.4 grams.
First of the resealable bags, 204.1 grams.
This is the Grab n Go. 255.1 grams.
Next bag up, the sharing
size. 442.3 grams.
The family size.
779.6 grams.
Hey, good enough for the
Egyptians, good enough for us.
Pyramids. Check 'em out.
This is the party pouch.
1.4 kilograms.
Have you noticed how good I
am at pouring these Skittles?
Can this be a job?
Forgive me for getting cocky,
but I haven't spilled one.
The biggest size, the jar.
1.53 kilograms.
Now, for "Food Wars" and
general-consumer purposes,
the 1-kilogram bag is our largest size.
However, I did want to point out this one.
A 1.6-kilogram bulk bag.
I was able to find one of these online
without too much hassle.
I think they are more aimed at, like,
vending-machine refills
rather than consumers,
but yeah, you are able to
get 1.6 kilograms of Skittles
if you are a massive
Skittles fan in the UK.
We also wanted to check how many Skittles
you're getting in each country
and also if there is
even color distribution.
So Joe has asked me to
count all of the Skittles
in a 1-kilogram pouch,
and we're also going to
sort them into colors
to see how many you get.
What color order makes the
most sense in your head?
The rainbow actually
has a order of colors?
To me, it's a bit of a ROYGBIV vibe.
I'm more of a CMYK guy.
Harry sorts Skittles and
asks you about your day ASMR.
Ah! Whoops. Whoo, God!
They're all running around
like they have personalities.
Just keep seeing the
yellow-and-purple color combination
and thinking of Waluigi.
Wah!
Eh and eh. All right!
OK, I have now sorted them by color.
It was satisfying, but it did take ages.
Now we have to count them all.
So now we gotta count these.
And I am not spending all
day counting these. So ...
Two ... four ...
I figure out how much 10 Skittles weigh.
Jot that down. Step two, weigh each cup,
obviously subtracting
the weight of the cup.
And then take the weight
of each cup, divide by 10.
Six ... eight ...
Three, four ...
Um ...
Is ...
After far too long spent
sorting and counting these,
we have our final totals.
I feel like we learned something,
but I don't know exactly what.
What have we learned from that?
Uh, do not do that at home.
It's an enormous waste of time.
We did some science today,
and that is the most important thing.
Now, while Skittles look the
same in both the US and the UK,
the flavors are actually different.
For example, in the UK, purple Skittles
are flavored with black currant.
Whereas in the US, our purple
Skittle is grape-flavored.
Back in the early 20th century,
the US government made it
illegal to grow black currants
because it was spreading
a wood-destroying disease.
Now, the ban has since been lifted,
but black currants never
really became popular
as a flavor here. Certainly
not as popular as grapes.
When it comes to tropical
Skittles in the UK,
the colors and flavors are as follows:
pineapple, orange, fruit punch,
watermelon, and passion fruit.
In the US, our tropical
Skittles flavors are
strawberry starfruit, which is pink;
mango tangelo, which is orange;
yellow is banana berry;
we don't have a purple one,
so we have a green one,
and it's kiwi lime;
and last here is pineapple
passion fruit, which is blue.
The Skittle-flavor controversies continue
with our wild berry Skittles in the UK.
A, because they contain cherry,
which is very much not a berry,
and also, B, because the
colors are all over the place.
We have cherry in the purple one.
Apple and blackberry with the green one.
Blueberry is the light blue one.
Raspberry is the pink one.
And then strawberry and kiwi for the red.
Our US wild berry
flavors are kind of close
to that of the UK's, and we
too have a non-berry cherry.
They even added "wild" onto the title,
but I'm not buying it.
Berry punch;
the raspberry, which is
blue, I don't know why;
wild cherry, which is not a berry;
green guy is melon berry;
and the pink one at the
end here is strawberry.
Now, if I had anything to say about this,
I think I'd mix the colors up as well.
I think in my mind, blue
raspberry would make more sense
than the current blue, which is blueberry.
I think blueberry would make
more sense as the purple one,
because as we all know, blueberry
isn't actually that blue.
It is more of a purple color.
And then I'd probably put
pink as the cherry one.
Full-flavor lineup. Ah!
And, of course, we have
Skittles Crazy Sours.
In the UK, our sour Skittles
are flavored and colored as follows:
we have sour cherry as the purple one;
we have sour green apple as the green one;
sour pineapple is the yellow one;
sour raspberry is the pink one;
and sour mandarin is the orange one.
In the US, Skittles sour
flavors are also different.
So, purple is grape.
This one says "the original lime-up,"
so I'm assuming green is now lime.
Yellow is lemon.
Red, strawberry.
And orange.
Do you think they're as crazy-sour
as the packaging suggests?
Let's go.
Oh, it's sour. Bleh!
A very sane level of sour, unfortunately.
We reached out to Skittles to ask them
about their flavor choices,
and they mentioned they had a variety
of methods of picking flavors,
one of which is something
called "social listening,"
which I assume means
checking social media.
And due to popular
complaints on social media,
the green Skittle was changed back to lime
after 10-ish years of being green apple.
With all this talk about flavors,
it's worth pointing out
that some people claim that
all Skittles might
actually taste the same.
In an interview with NPR,
neuropsychologist Don Katz,
who specializes in taste, said, quote,
"it is cheaper to make things
smell and look different
than it is to make them
actually taste different."
Dot dot dot.
So, Skittles have different
fragrances and different colors,
but they taste exactly the same.
This shouldn't come as too
much of a surprise to you,
because if you've been
stuffed up with a cold
or with allergies, you might know that
without your sense of smell,
food can seem rather tasteless.
That's because our sense
of smell is responsible
for a large percentage of what we taste.
General flavors like
salty, bitter, sweet, sour,
those can be detected without smell.
However, more complex flavors,
such as fruit,
require both taste and
smell to be recognized.
OK, Joe, I'm curious.
Let me see how many of
these original Skittles
I can identify correctly without
my sense of sight or smell.
So now, with the assistance
of Yuelei or Joe,
so I'm going to go ahead and do this,
and can someone please place
five Skittles in front of me,
and I will see if I can determine,
mask goes over the nose,
see if I can determine the flavor. Ready?
No. I mean, it's my mouth and my face.
Yuelei! What is going on
with my breath and my mouth
that I'm getting pink eye?
Harry: My God.
You sicko.
Joe: Hey, Joe, are you
going to try and trick me
by repeating flavors?
So, I've blindfolded myself.
Charlie has set five
Skittles in front of me.
I don't know which colors they are.
I'm going to hold my
nose as well, eat them,
and try and identify them.
First one.
Orange?
All right, wish me luck.
I really can't taste much.
That's tough! Wow.
I am literally just guessing.
I'm going to go purple. I have no idea.
All right, I need another one to compare.
That is making it way, way harder.
I think I got some more berry
vibes from the second one.
I think the first one was a bit more sour,
so it was either maybe an orange or lemon.
I can't decide. Like, red?
That one, I don't have a clue about.
Lemon, yellow?
Last one.
Uh, red.
This is way tougher than
I thought it would be.
I'm going to go with, like,
orange, strawberry,
lemon, green, and black currant, maybe.
Three out of five!
How'd I do?
[Joe laughing]
I couldn't taste anything.
You guys wanna try?
That was a lot harder than I
thought it was going to be.
I honestly think if I just
saw it and still plugged,
then I'd be like, "Yeah, I got orange."
Sight, however, does not
always play a significant role
in identifying flavors.
In June 2016, Skittles
released a limited-edition
all-white version of their product
in order to celebrate London Pride.
They've carried on doing this ever since,
stating on the packaging
that during Pride,
"only one rainbow matters."
So they ditch the rainbow in
order to honor Pride month,
which is a nice gesture on paper. However.
Apparently, some people took
this to mean white pride
and went on Twitter and
voiced said observation.
The good news is that despite that,
most people did still
appreciate the gesture,
so they have carried on doing it.
If they're all the same color,
how do you know which
Skittle you're getting?
It's actually way harder
to be, like, certain.
They have, like, a fruit flavor to them,
but they don't taste that fruity.
I was almost like, wait, did
they also omit the flavor?
So now, because I can't see the color,
I'm not quite sure what flavor it is.
Here are all the Skittles
products you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the exclusive
US Skittle flavors
you cannot get in the UK.
We'll start from this end
and work our way along.
So, in the UK, we can get Skittles Giants.
Now, apparently these are Skittles
which are three times the
size of regular Skittles.
They do look pretty beefy, I will say.
They are similar to
the regular UK Skittles
in that they still have the hard shell
and they are the same
flavors as the normal ones.
However, apparently they
have a softer inside as well.
My issue with this is they
do have a softer inside,
however, it reminds me
very much of chewing gum.
So everything in my brain
is now screaming at me
to not swallow this. I
don't think I like that.
If, for whatever reason, you don't like
the crispy shell on your Skittles,
then we've got you
covered, because in the UK,
you can get Skittles Chewies,
which are Skittles without a shell.
Something about these
just looks a little bit
off-putting to me.
It just kind of looks
like little balls of wax.
And again, something in your
brain kind of screams at you
and says, "Please do not eat this candle."
The flavor doesn't come
through as strongly
as it does from a regular
Skittle for some reason.
I feel like they must have
to coat them in something
to prevent them from all just
clumping together in the bag.
There's something kind of slimy going on
on the tongue right now,
which I am not a fan of.
I'm disappointed.
I'm not impressed.
This one, I mean, is this really a flavor?
It is the wild berry and
tropical mix, flavor mash-ups.
If there's ever been a lazier exclusive.
Take the two things we already
have, stick them in a bag.
Next up, we got Shriekers, Yuelei.
"Beware! If you dare. Shriekers.
Some are so sour they'll make you shriek."
OK.
[glass shattering]
What? What?
Are you shrieking? Like, is
it so sour you can't handle?
It can't be you're not sure.
No one has shrieked once.
These expired in May.
We have the America mix.
No one is more patriotic than I.
I bleed red, white, and blue.
Mostly red.
But this feels a little condescending.
Because it looks like they
just put the flag on it.
Like, what's the America mix?
Five flavors, three colors.
Oh! These are stale.
Yeah, they might have done
this several years ago.
Last exclusive flavor, we
have Brightside Skittles.
Remember that song "Mr. Brightside"?
♪ Wee-hoo I look just
like Mr. Brightside ♪
I love The Black Keys.
But it's kiwi banana, watermelon,
paradise punch, tangerine,
and pink lemonade.
That sounds a lot like the
tropical mix, doesn't it?
These are dusty.
Compared to
a seemingly much fresher USA one.
I should have googled how old these are.
It does. These taste like shampoo.
Our next UK exclusive is Squishy Cloudz.
It's another product from Skittles
in which they have kind
of ditched the shell
and gone for a more soft, chewy approach.
In the UK, these come in
both the standard flavors
and also the Crazy Sours flavors.
I don't know what I was expecting,
but we have these kind
of very soft, pillowy,
I guess Skittles.
It feels weird to call
this a Skittle, but.
I prefer these to the other
two that I've just tried.
So, as you can see, the sour version
has this kind of
granulated-sugar exterior,
whereas the classic version does not.
Skittles gummies. OK.
First glance, it feels like
they're taking away
the Skittleyness of it.
I mean, they're making
just round gummies now.
What's the difference
between Skittle gummies
and other fruit-flavored gummies?
And how much does the
shape affect the taste?
Look how many greens I
pulled out in one pinch!
Yep.
I'm a sucker for gummy.
I don't know why. I love gummy stuff.
These aren't very good.
I know gummy snacks
are maybe the most unnatural
delivery system for flavors.
But these taste woefully manufactured.
Why are my gummies sweaty?
Skittles, I think you got a
little more to learn about
gummy manufacturing, because these just,
these ain't it.
My boys in Sweden
are still kicking your butts
with their fish. Sorry.
Then we're on to the final
UK exclusive, which is this,
Skittles Stix ice cream bars.
The back of the packet describes them as,
"Fruity flavoured ice cream
with a secret sugar pearl centre."
Should I just bite into the whole thing?
Charlie: Yeah.
I feel like all of these
are different flavors of ice cream.
And one of them I am not enjoying,
and I can't quite tell which one it is.
Skittles freezer pops.
These have been sitting
in my freezer for a month.
I'm thrilled to get rid of them.
Orange, because it's on the side here.
Every summer at the pool just
trying to get this thing open,
just sitting there [growls].
Take me back, baby.
Those can stay in the past.
Last but not least, these guys.
Singles to go.
Little powder drinks. Make some juice.
Well, it's not real juice, right?
So, you got these little flavor pouches.
That's really funny. They
didn't even bother with lemon.
They're like, "who cares."
Little green apple juice.
Who doesn't love a
little green apple juice?
[lightning crackles]
Fun.
Yeah, very natural looking.
This is meant to be put in a water bottle.
Uh-oh!
It definitely has a strong odor.
Finally, they did it.
All the delicious flavor
of green-apple candy
in your water.
These are terrible.
You have to be wondering the same thing
that I'm wondering.
I would 100% have done
this when I was a kid.
The second I see these, I'm like,
"I'm putting them all in one,
and I'm going to chug it."
Oh, it's turning, like, a
brownie barf color, you see that?
This right here is called
tasting the rainbow.
[coughing]
Drink the rainbow!
I'll have one more sip.
Like a fine wine. Why -- wah!
You can also get kosher Skittles
and Skittles gum.
Original Skittles in the
UK contain the following.
Original Skittles in the US contain:
Artificial colors like Red 40, Yellow 5,
Yellow 6, and Blue 1
are restricted in the UK
because studies have linked
them to hyperactivity
and attention deficit in children.
Food and drink containing
these things in the UK
have to bear a warning label
about these potential adverse
affects, which means that
most manufacturers will
simply avoid using them.
But not here.
Also, one chemical you
won't be eating in the EU
anytime soon is titanium dioxide.
The European Food Safety Authority
found it could no longer
be considered safe
when used as a food additive.
Specifically, the panel concluded that
titanium dioxide particles
"have the potential
to induce DNA strand breaks
and chromosomal damage."
What?
Just feel my particles just pshh.
Harry: Breaking news coming to you live
from the "Food Wars" news desk.
Shortly after we recorded this episode,
Mars Inc. was actually hit
by a class-action lawsuit
in the US. The suit alleges that Skittles
are "unfit for human consumption"
due to the presence of titanium dioxide.
The suit points to the EFSA ruling
as well as the fact Mars themselves
had committed to removing
artificial colors
from their products back in 2016,
a promise they've since backtracked on.
Mars isn't backing down just yet,
telling The New York Times that its use
of titanium dioxide is "in compliance
with strict quality
and safety requirements
established by food safety
regulators, including the F.D.A."
We'll have to wait and
see how the trial unfolds
to see if there's any
bearing on food-safety laws
around titanium dioxide in the US
and potentially even the UK.
In slightly better news, standard Skittles
do not contain any animal-derived gelatin,
so they are suitable for vegans.
In the UK, a 45-gram bag of
Skittles contains 179 calories.
This entire bag is 250 calories, so.
We're going to quickly count these out
and figure out the
calorie count per Skittle.
How many Skittles in a bag?
Fifty ... two.
By my count, a 45-gram bag in the UK
contained around 52 Skittles.
That means that the calorie
count per Skittle is 3.44.
That's 4.24 calories per Skittle.
As for sugar content,
this tiny bag contains
66.4% of your recommended daily allowance.
That seems like a lot.
Gotta go bigger in the US. Ours is 90%.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Heinz products
in the UK and the US.
This is Food Wars.
Heinz is best known for its ketchup.
In the UK, it comes in the
following bottle sizes,
250 grams, 342 grams,
460 grams, 570 grams,
700 grams, 910 grams,
or our largest size, a
1.35-kilogram bottle.
I did also find a 1-kilogram bottle online
and I ordered some,
but unfortunately, it was stolen
from the lobby of our building.
So just imagine it there.
Heinz ketchup in the US also
comes in a variety of sizes.
Down at the end here, we
got the 14-ounce bottle.
Then we go up to a 20-ounce bottle.
We have a 32-ounce
bottle, 38-ounce bottle,
and the big juggy guy, 114 ounces.
What?
This can't be for like a family.
I guess if you just like dipping your food
and your fingers directly in there.
Nice.
Apparently, one serving
size for ketchup in the UK
is 15 grams,
which means that this
bottle contains 90 servings.
We're going to measure that out
and see if it seems realistic.
So according to Heinz in the UK,
that's one serving of ketchup.
That maybe looks like a bit less
than what I might normally
have with my meal,
if I was having say,
chips or something else,
which required dipping but not too bad.
The US serving size is 1 tablespoon,
which Heinz says is 17 grams of ketchup.
Let's take a look at that right now.
Got to do this.
You don't want to get that ketchup water
that comes out first.
That's the worst thing in the world.
You don't do this; you
get that ketchup water.
It's like, well, that's ruined.
Oh, it's like, oh 10, 13.
This is like when you're getting gas.
You want to get the exact dollar amount.
I've been training for this my whole life.
[Gasping]
Yay!
17 grams of ketchup.
That means that this 114-ounce jug
contains 190 servings of this right here.
That seems like a reasonable amount.
Here are all the Heinz
products from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
We finally have way more than America.
Come on.
And here are all the
Heinz products in the US
you won't find in the UK.
Do they have more than us?
I feel like we have more.
Let's find out.
In the UK, we can get two
exclusive varieties of ketchup.
We can get ketchup up with 50%
less added sugar and salt
as well as ketchup with
no added sugar and salt.
And these are exclusives here in the US,
because we have them singularly.
A no salt added and a no sugar added.
Some of the exclusive ketchups we have are
jalapenño ketchup.
Oooh. Sriracha-flavored ketchup.
Ooh.
Not bad, but just taste more
garlicky than anything else.
Hot and spicy Tabasco ketchup.
Also, we have ketchup
with a blend of veggies,
kids approved.
I mean, I'm assuming this is to trick kids
into eating more vegetables.
I think it's better than none, right?
I'm curious.
That tastes exactly like
ketchup, which is good, right?
Trying to trick kids into
eating vegetables. This is it.
You can also get simple tomato ketchup
with no artificial sweeteners
and tomato ketchup
sweetened only with honey,
not available at the time
of filming this segment.
What the UK might lack in
exclusive ketchup options,
we make up for with our mayonnaise.
Over here, we can get light mayonnaise.
The existence of light mayo
implies the existence of
a forbidden dark mayo,
just a heads-up.
We have a vegan mayo option.
Our other vegan options
include this vegan chili mayo
as well as this vegan mayo/garlic aioli.
Then we have some seriously
good mayo options,
including this garlic
and caramelized onion one
as well as this rich
and creamy truffle mayo.
I don't like how they've had to
create a fancy brand of mayo.
I feel like nobody should
be too good for mayo.
If you think you're too
good for mayo, you're wrong.
The Heinz website also advertised
a lemon and black pepper mayo,
which unfortunately I
couldn't find anywhere.
The mustard option you
get in the US exclusively
are the 100% natural spicy brown mustard,
a Heinz 100% natural honey mustard.
And, of course, organic yellow mustard.
Heinz sells two types
of mustard in the UK,
a mild mustard and a honey mustard,
but they were strangely
hard to track down.
I did find the mild mustard online,
but that was also one of the things stolen
along with our ketchup.
So enjoy that as well.
Barbecue sauces, USA,
we love our barbecue.
We love our barbecue sauces.
The first one is the
Carolina mustard-style,
sweet mustard barbecue sauce.
I'm like stoked for this one.
When these arrived, I was like, hell yeah.
I want to try these sauces.
Ooh.
Fantastic.
Yep.
We got the Carolina vinegar-style,
sweet and tangy barbecue sauce.
I like this one, too.
There's a Kansas City-style
sweet and smoky barbecue sauce,
I could not get it at
the time of filming this.
But I was able to get
the original sweet and thick barbecue.
I mean, barbecue sauce is
like the best thing ever.
Well, they weren't kidding. That is thick.
The Texas barbecue sauce, bold and spicy.
Just like the state.
Also thick.
Oh my goodness.
I'd do this one or this one.
These are the two best ones.
I can't decide: Carolina or Texas?
We only have two barbecue
sauce options in the UK,
a sweet barbecue sauce and
a classic barbecue sauce.
I'm not sure how it compares
to the original sweet option in the US
or how they've managed to kind
of isolate those two flavors.
I don't think like original/classic
can be a flavor in itself.
Vinegars!
Let's go.
Distilled white vinegar, 5% acidity.
What does it mean by 5% acidity?
Great question.
Well, you see. I have no idea.
Then we also got the Heinz
gourmet malt vinegar.
We also have a salad vinegar,
gourmet salad vinegar.
Yum.
We have a gourmet tarragon vinegar. Ooh.
All-natural apple cider vinegar,
a organic unfiltered apple
cider vinegar with the mother,
question mark, question
mark, question mark.
Yeah, I don't know what that means either.
We have a Heinz all-natural, multipurpose,
extra-strength vinegar with a 6% acidity.
And, of course, the Heinz imported
balsamic vinegar from Modena.
Well, in the UK, Heinz
just has malt vinegar,
which I couldn't find today,
but it does go great
on your fish and chips.
We have got so many gravies.
Gravy, as I know it,
you pour it on mashed
potatoes and sometimes turkey.
It's like a brown sauce,
sometimes a white sauce.
You can also get biscuits
and gravy for breakfast,
which is fantastic. That sauce is white.
We got a lot of different
variations of gravy.
I can't be the US gravy ambassador.
All right, I didn't ask for this job.
At no point in the interview -
and they was like, well, you know
a lot about gravies, right?
And if I said I did, I lied, all right?
Please revoke my gravy ambassador status,
and I'm sorry for deceiving
the people of Food Insider.
Heinz homestyle gravy with mushroom,
there's mushrooms in it.
I see gravy twice a year,
once at Thanksgiving
and once when I go to Jollibee.
And then you got the savory
beef gravy, bistro au jus,
signature gravy, rich and savory,
made with roasted turkey. Let's go.
We got the country-style sausage gravy.
This goes, yes, see he's
pouring it on biscuits.
It's a breakfast. It's a breakfast gravy.
It comes with a country
sausage and hashbrowns recipe.
Joe, I don't know what that
is, but that is not gravy.
That looks horrific.
Especially that creamy
stuff, like why is it white?
Gravy should never be white.
Classic chicken grav...
this is like not white.
It's more of like a khaki-colored gravy.
Now, that isn't even close
to the amount of gravies
you can get in the US.
I went to several grocery stores, several,
looking for these gravies,
as many as I could find.
So, I'm going to rattle off the list.
Signature rich and savory gravy
with real roasted chicken.
The homestyle brown with onion gravy.
Heinz homestyle classic
chicken fat-free gravy.
Homestyle pork gravy.
And, last but not least,
homestyle savory beef fat-free gravy.
British gravy is either made from
the juices and drippings of a roast dinner
or made by adding water
to some gravy granules.
Not a Heinz brand, just a good brand.
I like Bisto.
Thankfully, we don't have any of that
American gravy in the UK.
But what we do have is salad cream
or "salad queen" as it's currently called
in honor of the Queen's Platinum Jubilee.
It's just what Liz
would've wanted, I'm sure.
Now Americans, don't be
alarmed by salad cream.
I know the name sounds
a little off-putting,
but it's actually not that bad.
It's basically just mayo
that they've added some kind of vinegar
and also a little bit of sugar to.
So it's kinda like a tangy mayo,
which you can add to your
salads or to your sandwiches.
I feel like with Americans,
some of the things that
they pass off as salads,
they have no right to
criticize a salad cream.
You ever seen, I think it's
ambrosia salad in America,
which is basically just
loads of mayo anyway.
Pickles and relish.
I think relish is just
okay. Not a fan of pickles.
The hot dog relish. Why is it this color?
Why is it this color?
If I got a hot dog and
they put this relish on it,
I'd be like, yeah, you're
making it again without that.
Dill relish, right?
Just straightforward from dill pickles,
or they add a dill to it.
What do you think?
Burger fans, get yourself
a Hamburger Dill Chips.
Other pickle stroke relish options
that we have here in the US are,
genuine whole original sour dill pickles,
spicy garlic chips with
garlic and red pepper,
sweet and spicy chips
with crushed red pepper,
sweet gherkins.
We don't have Heinz pickles in the UK,
but we do have Heinz pickle.
This is an important
distinction to make in the UK,
'cause if you ask for just
pickle singular on your sandwich,
you'll end up with this.
This is an iconic British condiment,
which is either served as
part of your ploughman's lunch
or on a sandwich, like
a cheese and pickle.
It's a thick condiment made
with some cooked vegetables
like carrots, swedes,
cauliflower, and onions,
all served in this kind
of thick, tangy sauce.
We also have Heinz Piccalilli in the UK.
It's sort of similar
to ploughman's pickle,
in that it's a spreadable condiment
with some crunchy cooked
vegetables inside,
but it's also different because
it's got the mustard base,
which gives it this
distinctive yellow color.
I will say, it's kind of
an old person's condiment.
I don't think you'll really see anyone
under the age of 50 or so in the UK
rushing for the Piccalilli,
but it is tasty.
Next up, Heinz US offers a
bunch of specialty sauces,
Heinz 57 sauce, real talk,
I've never heard of
this before this video.
It says that it adds zest to
chicken, steak, or pork.
Doesn't this sound like
a weird thing to say,
but doesn't this look really good.
So, let's find out.
First, the sniff test.
I like how it smells.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
Yeah, that's really good.
I can't place my finger
on exactly what it is.
Ah, secret blend of
premium herbs and spices.
Oh man, it's like liquid KFC apparently.
It's like, like a mustard base,
but like a sweeter and zestier
like punctuation to it.
Ooh. Heinz 57 chili sauce.
I got to say Heinz, don't be putting this,
"great on burgers and fries."
Don't tell me what to put my sauce on.
I'll brush my teeth
with this if I want to.
You're not going to stop me.
Yeah. That would be great
on my burgers and/or fries.
The Heinz original cocktail sauce.
I'm not opening this, you know,
shrimp, you get it, cocktails.
I have no opinion on cocktail sauce.
Worcestershire sauce.
Couldn't get my hands on it.
But I do think that it's weird
that Heinz also makes its own Wor-
Worcestershire sauce.
Worcestershire, Worcestershire?
Is that right?
Now, they also own Lea and Perrins,
so are they competing against themselves?
I don't think so. I
think they just bought it
'cause they're Heinz.
You think like,
I'm not getting the Heinz
Worcestershire sauce,
I'm getting the Lea and Perrins.
That joke's on you. Heinz
gets paid on all that.
Firstly, that should
be speciality sources,
with the extra "i."
And, secondly, in the UK,
we also have a range of
specialty condiments.
We have an American-style,
smoky baconnaise sauce
and also an American-style burger sauce.
Do these actually look or
feel American to you, Joe?
Yes. That looks like sauce
that we potentially have.
Then we have a Thai-style,
sweet chili sauce.
British people love
Thai sweet chili sauce.
I don't know where that
association came from,
but I'm not losing pain,
'cause it's delicious.
And we have a Turkish-style garlic sauce.
I think this is kind of a nod to the
Turkish-style kebab shops,
which are so popular in the UK.
Drunk kebab is one of the
best pleasures in life.
Speaking of drunk food,
we also have Heinz curry sauce in the UK.
You don't have to be drunk to enjoy it,
but it does help.
Cheesy chips and curry sauce
is a big British hit.
Next up, we have a
spiced pineapple chutney
as well as a North
African-style spicy kebab sauce
made with chili and onion.
Why doesn't ketchup and mustard
come in the same bottle?
We all scream to the heavens.
Apparently, Heinz has a whole thing called
sauces mixed by Heinz.
'Cause God forbid you just do it yourself.
Some of these, I mean.
I didn't even know
you wanted them together to begin with.
Who knows how they figured this out?
Honeyracha, what do you think that is?
Surely, you watching at home
understand the value of
having a bottle of Sriracha
and a bottle of honey.
The amount of times you mix them
must pale in comparison,
amount of times you
don't need to mix them.
Actually, that's pretty good though.
Then we got Mayochup.
[Laughing]
Yeah. Mayo and ketchup together at last.
Oh God. Nope.
Even by these standards, it's really bad.
Up next,
Kranch.
Just call it ranch and ketchup.
Two things I never combine anyway.
Oh, there's like chunks
of (censored) in it, too.
Oh, this one. Okay.
Both the ketchup connection ones.
This tastes almost exactly like ranch
and the ketchup mayo one, was it Mayochup?
Taste just like mayo.
Buffaranch.
I'll concede, Buffalo and
ranch in the same thing,
I understand this one.
[Liquid squirting]
Oh, that was the bottle, not me.
That was me.
I went from hating this to loving it
in like two seconds.
This might be genius. I'm taking this one.
This is actually pretty good.
And this would go really good on
any potatoes or fries.
Of course, on chicken.
Oh my God, with popcorn
chicken, this would be ideal.
Oh my God. Mayomust.
This one works just fine.
You know what it's like.
It tastes like a creamy mustard.
You can also get yourself
a Mayoracha sauce
and, ugh, God,
and this last one. Come on, guys.
Sweet Ketchili sauce,
which I'm assuming is sweet
ketchup and chili sauce.
Ugh.
We only have one premixed
sauce option in the UK
and it's this, Saucy Sauce.
I'm not sure why they've
gone with this name
instead of Mayochup.
Because, as far as I can see,
it is just mayo and ketchup combined.
Another thing worth touching upon is
HP versus A.1. sauce.
The great HP, A.1. divide.
I mean, there's literally like
a rip through the Atlantic Ocean.
It's a sauce that's meant to be on meat,
mostly steak and hamburgers.
In the UK, Heinz produces
another iconic condiment,
HP sauce.
It's a sauce, which is also designed
to be enjoyed with meats like sausages
or on your bacon sandwich.
I'm more of a ketchup on
the bacon sandwich guy,
but you do you.
You have to understand,
that when A.1. sauce dropped,
it was that time in the '80s
where marketing was so crazy effective.
Obviously, there's no internet,
so we all watched the
same five to 10 channels
and you couldn't look at a TV
without seeing an A1
steak sauce commercial,
from like 1985 to 1989.
Ta-da! A.1. steak sauce.
And it was on the table,
and we just put it on
and like licking the knife, like, oh yeah,
A.1., look at us, we got A.1.
This [censored] is nasty.
I'm not nostalgic for it. I don't like it.
I don't put sauces on meats like steak.
Oh God.
It's so tangy.
HP sauce is better than this.
I forgot to bring my bottle.
To give you an idea of just how
British this sauce is,
HP actually stands for
Houses of Parliament,
as you can maybe infer from the fact
that they are right there on the label.
HP sauce is part of a
subcategory of sauces in the UK,
which are called brown sauces.
While it might not sound very appetizing,
it's really popular in the UK,
as evidenced by the fact that
it's not even the only brown sauce
Kraft Heinz produces.
We also have Daddy's brown sauce.
Yes, this is a real thing.
It wouldn't be a Heinz episode
unless I talked about baked beans.
In the UK, Heinz doesn't just
manufacture condiments but also
an enormous range of canned goods.
The most iconic of these
is probably Heinz beans.
I'd say Heinz is probably
the gold standard
for baked beans in the UK.
As you may know, British
people love to eat baked beans,
with a range of dishes, including
a full English breakfast,
sausage mash and beans, fish
fingers, chips, and beans.
And, of course, beans on toast.
Baked beans.
So I'm going to say right off the bat,
going to show my Americanness right now.
Beans for breakfast sounds absurd.
Now granted, we have
sausage, gravy, and potatoes
and chicken-fried steak.
So I know that our breakfasts
are very questionable.
Beans for breakfas-
Like beans, beans on toast?
No, no, no, no.
No, thank you.
My only issue with Heinz beans
is the stupid beans with the "z" spelling.
I think it was part of
some marketing campaign
from back in the '80s or '70s,
and they just never let it go.
But I will say, British
beans are generally
served in quite a sweet tomato sauce,
which does go with quite a few dishes.
I feel like American beans are different.
Yeah. Beans like here, like they're baked.
They usually come in like a barbecue sauce
or a barbecue-like sauce.
You get them at barbecue places, right?
Like picnic food, right?
Beans aren't even the only canned goods
that Heinz sells in the UK.
They have a huge range of
soups, canned pastas, and more.
Heinz soups are pretty
highly regarded in the UK.
I like the big soups 'cause I feel like
a standard can of soup
isn't enough for an actual meal.
But some of the other
flavors are really good.
The classic tomato can't really be beaten.
Heinz canned pastas don't have
quite the same reputation,
but I will fight to the death
to defend the beef ravioli.
I ate so much of that growing up,
and I still have such a strong nostalgic
attachment to it. That
if anyone criticizes it,
you know where to find me.
And there are even more food options
from Heinz in the UK, including jars of
pasta sauce, salad dressings, and
veggie burger options.
Heinz covers so many
product areas in the UK
that they even have a
huge range of baby foods.
I picked up this peach,
mango, banana, and apple one,
because it sounds delicious,
and I am technically older than 4 months,
so I think I can eat this.
Here's everything in
Heinz ketchup in the US.
Tomato concentrate from red, red tomatoes;
distilled vinegar;
high-fructose corn syrup;
corn syrup; salt; spice;
onion powder; natural flavor.
Here's everything on the ingredients list
for ketchup in the UK.
Tomatoes, spirit vinegar, sugar, salt,
spice and herb extracts,
contains celery and spice.
There are a few obvious differences
between the two lists.
The spices listed are slightly different.
With ours explicitly
containing onion powder.
That's not to say the UK's
doesn't also contain onion powder,
as it may just fall under the
spice and herb extract
subcategory in the UK.
Our label also explicitly lists celery
as an ingredient,
largely for allergen purposes.
In the US, our ketchup is sweetened
with both corn syrup and
high-fructose corn syrup,
while the UK, they just
sweeten theirs with sugar.
Americans put corn syrup
in absolutely everything
because it's cheaper for
food producers to use
when compared to real sugar.
That's because corn farmers in the US
receive huge subsidies
from the government,
more than 116 billion since 1995,
leading to massive corn production.
We also have tariffs,
which make it more expensive
to import real sugar.
There isn't really a
health difference when
comparing the consumption
of sugar and corn syrup,
but there can be a
discernible taste difference.
For example, American Coca-Cola
is flavored with high-fructose corn syrup
while Mexican Coke is flavored with sugar.
When comparing the taste of the two,
some people said that the American version
was an even sweeter taste
but also had a slightly chemical flavor.
Are there any other ingredients
to look out for across
Heinz product range?
In the US, we have pickles that contain
polysorbate 80, a chemical used in foods
like pickles and ice cream
as an emulsifier and a solubilizer.
A solubilizer, solubilizer?
Solubilizer.
The bad news is that
studies have suggested
it can cause colon cancer in mice.
You know what that means.
Give me them dancing rats.
Also in the US, our Heinz colors,
it's sausage gravy with titanium dioxide.
This is a white dye most commonly used
in paints and varnishes.
Delicious.
Its use in food is controversial.
Studies show it has
harmful effects on animals
during scientific tests, leading the
European Union to ban
it from use in foods,
starting in August of 2022.
Due to Brexit however,
the UK is no longer bound
by EU rules about food.
Unfortunately, for Brits and Americans,
our respective food-safety authorities
have actually disagreed
with the EU ruling.
So we may still see titanium dioxide
popping up in our food.
Here's everything in 100
grams of original ketchup
in the UK.
102 calories, 0.1 grams of total fat,
of which 0 grams are saturates,
23.2 grams of carbs, of
which 22.8 grams are sugars,
and 720 milligrams of sodium.
Here's everything in 100 grams
of ketchup in the US.
117 calories, no fat, 29.4 carbs.
And, of that, 23.5 grams of that is sugar.
And the sodium is 941 milligrams.
Other than the trace amounts
of fat in the UK ketchup,
the US stats are higher in every category.
Now these stats are for
100 grams of ketchup,
which is roughly five times a recommended
serving size, which is 1 tablespoon.
That's still a surprising
amount of sugar and sodium.
Just 100 grams of ketchup in the US
contain almost half your
daily sugar allowance
as well as 40% of your daily sodium.
It's also worth checking
out the serving size,
because companies have a habit
of underestimating these.
Let's bring out the serving
size we measured earlier.
I still think that's a little bit smaller
than what I'd normally add to my plate.
So I'm going to add some more to it
and then figure out the stats for
what I think is a realistic serving size.
I don't think that's unrealistic.
Judge me if you want.
That's actually more than double
the recommended serving size, coming in
at around 31 grams. Let's figure it out.
Okay. So if I had fries, I'd probably go.
Not that long, right?
This is 20 grams.
Ahh, that doesn't seem so bad.
And also, I don't think...I
don't think I'm eating all that.
I don't think all of this
is getting in my body.
I think this would be smeared around.
And so here in America, not concerned.
This one's for you, Papa.
I like pickled onion, I like Piccalilli.
Pickled cabbage is all right
with bubble and squeak on a Friday night.
I like tomatoes, but what I do prefer
is a little bit of I
come, you come, we come,
a little bit of cucumber. Oy!
Ta-da.
Imagine when that dropped in like 1920.
People would've lost their minds.